Das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch.
Und jetzt kommt Schuppan, 1 zu 0, 42. Minute, sein drittes Tor schon in dieser Saison. Wieder Freistoß Bielefeld und diesmal Sebastian Schuppan mit dem 1 zu 1. Müller lässt durch, Schuppan, 2 zu 0 und jetzt webt die Alm.
Leverkusen, das wird so ein Tor bleiben, was mir ewig in meiner Erinnerung sein wird, so wie das ganze Spiel, so was erlebt man vielleicht nur einmal als Fußballer. So ein Erstligist nach 3-0 Rückstand rauszuhauen, das ist eine einmalige Sache, glaube ich, und das werde ich noch meinen Enkeln erzählen, was da los war.
Ja, er soll es nicht seinen Enkeln erzählen, beziehungsweise denen gerne auch und gerne auch den Enkelinnen, aber jetzt erstmal mir im Rasenfunk im Tribünengespräch. Hallo liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer hier im Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch und hallo Sebastian Schuppan. Wir wollen heute über deine Karriere sprechen. Ich habe mich schon gestern durch sämtliche YouTube-Videos von dir durchgeklickt, die es so gibt und dadurch dieses Intro zusammen geschnipselt, um dich kurz vorzustellen den Hörerinnen und Hörern. Du bist jetzt 31 Jahre alt, hast schon über 17.000 Minuten Profifußballerfahrung, das ist natürlich eine Zahl, die dir klar geläufig ist, fast 250 Spiele in zweiter und dritter Liga für Cottbus, Paderborn, Dresden, Bielefeld und jetzt für die Würzburger Kickers. Du bist noch aktiv, spießt auf der linken Außenbahn, freue mich sehr, dass du mit dabei bist.
Sergio Radu noch vorne drin, das fand ich wahnsinnvoll.
Der kam erst im Aufstiegsjahr, also der kam erst in der ersten Liga, glaube ich. Also das war jetzt das Aufstieg, ich weiß nicht, war er da schon dabei im Aufstiegsjahr?
Er steht schon im Kader und hat auch 33 Spiele gemacht.
Er kam dann erst im nächsten Jahr bei der Monteano. Dann war dann die Rumänen-Connection quasi perfekt. Der wurde dann für mich verpflichtet in der ersten Liga. Also um nochmal zurückzukommen, wir hatten halt eine Wahnsinns-Saison. Ich habe, glaube ich, 23 oder 24 Spiele gemacht. Da gab es auch mal Phasen, wo ich dann zwei, drei Spiele nicht so funktioniert habe, wie er sich das vorgestellt hat. Dann hat er mich dann auch mal wieder zwei Spiele spielen lassen, um zu sagen, du brauchst einfach auch die Spielpraxis, was ich völlig okay fand. Ich war damals nicht so vermessen zu sagen, dass ich immer kommen musste oder so. Das war für mich vollkommen okay. Ich glaube, ich habe ein paar Spiele in der Oberliga damals bei der zweiten Liga gemacht.
Genau, du hast ein paar in der zweiten Mannschaft gemacht, das war ganz ordentlich. Aber das entscheidende Spiel, es war der Aufstieg in die erste Fußballbundesliga, auch sensationell damals, da wird sich vielleicht auch die eine oder andere Hörerin und der eine oder andere Hörer noch dran erinnern. Und beim entscheidenden Spiel zu Hause gegen 1860, 13-1 gewonnen, 20 auf der Bank, Leandro.
Das war so ein Zwischending. Der Trainer wusste, ich hatte auch mein Abi in dem Jahr gemacht. Der Trainer wusste das natürlich alles, weil es da eine ganz enge Verzahnung gab zwischen Schule und Verein. Der Trainer hat auch gemerkt, dass ich am Ende ein bisschen überfordert war mit allem zusammen. Der Trainer wollte mir das nicht aufheizen, obwohl ich mir natürlich gewünscht hätte, dass er mich da noch ein paar Minuten gebracht hätte zum Schluss. Aber ich habe mich trotzdem als volles Mitglied der Mannschaft gefühlt und habe auch meinen Beitrag dazu geleistet. Ich bin mit 18 Jahren in die Erstliga aufgestiegen. Das war natürlich irgendwie Wahnsinn. Am Anfang der Saison waren wir fast Absteiger davor. Keiner hatte von uns was erwartet und wir sind aufgestiegen. Immer noch unglaublich für mich heute. Also mein verrückteste Aufstieg, den keiner vorher gesehen hat. Wir haben uns da so zusammengeschworen als Truppe. Und es war einfach Wahnsinn, muss ich sagen. Also für mein erstes richtiges Profi-Jahr konnte es eigentlich nichts Besseres geben.
Und wie war die Aufstiegsfeier?
Die Aufstiegsfeier war, man als 18-Jähriger, ich habe mich letztens daran versucht zu erinnern, ich habe nur Mist gemacht, glaube ich, im Endeffekt.
Wenn du dich nicht gut dran erinnern kannst, spricht es für eine sehr, sehr gute Aufstiegsfeier.
Nein, es ging eigentlich. Mir persönlich, wir sind dann mit dem Bus durch die Stadt gefahren, das war alles sensationell. Dann auf dem Stadthallenplatz haben wir uns dann feiern lassen. Da habe ich auch das erste Mal dann so eine kleine Anekdote mitbekommen. Da hat man ja dann früher gesagt, hier diese Fangesänge, dann scheiß Aue, scheiß Rostock und so. Und da habe ich Baumi neben mir noch im Ohr und stehen sehen, singen das nicht? Mein Freund hat gesagt, singen so etwas nicht. Du weißt nicht, wie der Fußball ist. Vielleicht spielst du in zwei Jahren bei einem von den Vereinen. Und dann kommt das Video raus, hier, wo du gebrüllt hast, scheiß Rostock. In dem Moment habe ich natürlich gesagt, Baumi, bitte, machen wir es jetzt nicht. Lass mich doch mal ein bisschen herumschreien. Alles gut. Im Endeffekt war es dann wirklich so, das ist nicht bei mir, aber bei Lars Jungnickel. Der hat das auch geschrien und der ist dann später zu Dynamo Dresden gegangen. Und dann haben die das genau rausgeholt, dieses Video. Und da habe ich dann gedacht, ok, baumi, Bismarad war ein bisschen auf den Sack gegangen damals, aber da hat schon viel gestimmt. Da hat er gesagt, sowas macht man nicht, macht sowas nicht. Das ist alles schön und gut, das können die Fans singen, das ist in Ordnung. Aber du als Spieler, halt dich da ein bisschen zurück. Das war so eine kleine Lehrstunde, die ich da noch in dieser Euphorie mitbekommen habe. Und sonst war ich dann wirklich viel zu schnell besoffen natürlich und bin dann irgendwie um eins oder so völlig fertig irgendwo eingepennt. Keine Ahnung, ob ich im Club da eingepennt bin oder wo wir dann waren. Cottbus war jetzt natürlich klar auch nicht so riesig. Wir waren dann so im Club abends, wie gesagt, aber viel zu schnell besoffen und also nicht genossen. Ich weiß noch, Baumi hat sich mit einer Zigarre auf die Tribüne gesetzt und hat zugeguckt, wie wir da Spektakel im Stadion veranstaltet haben und rumgehüpft sind und alles. Und er hat gesagt, mach dir mal, ich genieße das auf meine Art und Weise. Das fand ich damals irgendwie seltsam, aber jetzt im Nachhinein, als ich mit Bielfeld aufgestiegen bin, habe ich es ähnlich versucht und ich fand es ganz cool, dass du von außen betrachtest, mit ein bisschen Abstand zu sehen und die Jungen mal machen lassen und ein bisschen genießen. Dann kannst du es tatsächlich ein bisschen mehr genießen, muss ich sagen, mit ein bisschen Abstand.
Oh ja, ich hatte auch mehrere Geburtstagsfeiern, auf denen ich komplett nüchtern war, aber alle dachten irgendwie, ich würde immer. Protipp, in die Cola mit Eiswürfeln, einfach Limettenscheiben rein, dann denken alle, du trinkst Kuba Libre. Und dann kann man der kompletten Gesellschaft dabei zugucken, wie alle immer lauter und betrunkener werden. Und das ist auf mehrere Arten und Weisen interessant und aber auch verstörend. Aber generell ist ja – also ich will jetzt überhaupt nicht so eine Aufstiegsfeier irgendwie zerreden – aber Alkohol und Profifußball ist ja schon ein Thema. Also Alkohol ist generell ein Thema. Die Alkoholismusrate ist viel höher in Deutschland, als man denken würde. Andererseits, wenn man mal mit offenen Augen durch die Stadt läuft, sieht man da auch sehr viele Leute. Wie war denn das damals? Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sich da auch einiges verändert hat im Fußball. Denn wenn ich heute von Fußballern höre, die sich glutenfrei – und ich esse nur noch Dinge, die keinen Schatten werfen, also wie beim Simpsons – ernähren, dann kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass heutzutage das Spieltagsfeierabendbier bei allen noch mit dazugehört. Damals war es aber vermutlich noch ein bisschen anders.
Ja, also klar, damals hat jeder, die alten Spieler, die haben immer vor dem Spiel ihr Bierchen getrunken, abends im Hotel. Abends im Hotel, wenn wir vor den Spielen waren, haben die immer ihr Bierchen getrunken, auf jeden Fall. Also ganz viele, muss ich sagen. Heute siehst du das wirklich vereinzelt nur noch, möchte ich sagen. Also ich würde sagen, da gibt es vielleicht in jeder Mannschaft noch einen oder maximal zwei, die das vielleicht machen. Aber alles auf ihrem Zimmer. Früher sind sie da in die Bar gegangen und haben da ihr Bierchen getrunken und die Trainer fanden das vollkommen in Ordnung. Ich weiß, dass Peter Neuro, was er heutzutage immer noch hin und wieder mal macht mit der Mannschaften, vor dem Spiel abends mal ein Bierchen trinkt. Und das habe ich zumindest gehört. Also keine gesicherte Quelle, aber relativ gesichert, sagen wir mal so. Und heutzutage wird natürlich nichts mehr dem Zufall überlassen. Damals hat es auch keinen interessiert. Da waren Jungs auch mal Mittwochs weg, wenn wir Samstag Spiel hatten. Also das hat einfach keinen interessiert. Heutzutage macht einer ein Foto von dir und zack, bist du dran. Das ist natürlich alles ein bisschen anders. Früher war es einfach wirklich… Früher, das hört sich so an. Ich bin echt so alt, 31.
Du bist ja jünger als ich. Was glaubst du, wie sich das für mich anfühlt, wenn du…
Früher hört es sich komisch an, aber da gab es viel mehr Alkohol auf jeden Fall. Auch unter der Woche und so. Also wirklich, muss man echt sagen, hat sich deutlich gewandelt heutzutage. Fast gar nicht mehr. Also wirklich andere Zeit.
Und dann Erstligasaison, Energie Cottbus, sensationeller Aufstieg. Aber du hast kein Erstligaspiel gemacht. Warum?
Das ist eins der dunkelsten Jahre meiner Laufbahn.
Das musst du unheimlich frustierend gewesen sein.
Ja, also ich habe mich in der Vorbereitung im Spiel gegen Chemnitz, habe ich mir einen Meniskusriss zugezogen. Das war relativ nah am ersten Spiel, ich glaube so drei Wochen vor dem ersten Spiel. Und das war eigentlich keine große Sache, haben die gesagt. Und ich bin dann nach Halle zur OP, zu Dr. Bartels. Der war damals so eine Koryphäe und da hat gesagt, kein Problem, das kriegen wir hin. Er hat mich operiert und innerhalb von zwei Wochen stand ich wieder auf dem Platz. Also sensationell quasi, fast schon. Und habe dann ein Vorbereitungsspiel wieder gemacht. Habe super mit dem Reha-Trainer gearbeitet. Das war, glaube ich, eine der schnellsten Genesungen nach einem Meniskusriss gewesen, die es gab. Aber Puste Kuchen. Nach diesem Spiel, das war am Ende des Trainingslagers, bin ich nach Hause und am nächsten Morgen bin ich aufgewacht und hatte so einen Ballon dran. Knie unfassbar dick. Ich dachte, was ist los? Ich tat auch nicht weh, es war einfach nur unfassbar dick. Und zum Arzt gefahren. Da hatte ich das Gefühl, dass ich 15-mal punktiert habe, die Tage über, und keiner wusste, was los war. Ich hatte keine großen Schmerzen, aber es war unfassbar dick. Ich konnte nichts machen. Ich bin zehn Minuten Fahrrad gefahren und sofort wieder vollgelaufen. Und dann bin ich wieder zum Bartels gefahren nach Halle. Und dann ist rausgekommen, dass wir nochmal operieren müssen. Er hat gesagt, das war nicht so richtig ein OP-Fehler, aber er hat gesagt, bei jungen Kerlen wie dir versucht man so wenig wie möglich Meniskus wegzunehmen, weil es eine Resektomie war. Wir haben rausgenommen, nicht genäht. Und er hat gesagt, vielleicht war es ein bisschen zu wenig, was ich weggenommen habe. Und dann haben sie richtig ausgeschalt, also dann haben sie fast alles vom Meniskus weggenommen. Und dann war es nicht so richtig besser trotzdem, es war immer dick. Und dann hat der Dr. Bartels irgendwann gesagt, da muss irgendwas sein, irgendwas ist da. Und dann haben wir noch mal so eine Blutuntersuchung gemacht, so eine spezielle. Und dann ist halt rausgekommen, dass ich so einen Bakterienbefall hatte im Knie. Und das war dann halt für mich damals so ein richtiger Schlag. Also der hat gesagt, ja, das sind so Klamydien, so ein Bakterienstamm und den müssen wir jetzt rausholen mit Antibiotika. Und dann habe ich eine Woche Antibiotika genommen und da hat er gesagt, das müsste reichen. Dann haben wir eine Blutuntersuchung gemacht und noch viel mehr Bakterien gewesen. Dann habe ich, ich glaube…
Fängt man da irgendwann auch an zum Zweifeln am Arzt?
Ja, ja schon. Obwohl ich ehrlich gesagt sagen muss, dass der mir trotzdem immer irgendwie ein gutes Gefühl gegeben hat. Ich meine, er war der, der es entdeckt hat überhaupt, dass es eine Bakteriengeschichte war. Und ohne ihn, weiß nicht aus Cottbus, die haben sich halt dumm und dämlich geraten, was es sein könnte, haben alles mögliche kontrolliert. Aber er war halt der auch am Ende, der es rausgefunden hat. Und dann habe ich noch mal 15 Tage Antibiotika umgenommen. Volle kann ich sagen, ich kann mich an das Mannschaftsfoto erinnern. Ich war weiß wie die Wand dahinter. Also ich habe, mein Körper war komplett auf Null. Alles hat mich angestrengt. Ich war komplett, wirklich, dann waren es insgesamt, glaube ich, zwei, drei Monate, die ich ausgefallen bin. Ich glaube, ich bin im Oktober oder November wieder zurückgekommen. Aber ich war so weit davon entfernt, ich zu sein, dass es wirklich Wahnsinn war. Also ich hätte mich als Trainer selbst nicht wahrgenommen. Also ich habe dann bis zum Winter wirklich versucht mitzutrainieren. Habe das auch gemacht, aber war lange nicht in der Verfassung, dass ich für irgendetwas fähig war, geschweige denn für ein Erstligaspiel. Und habe dann wirklich auch in der Rückrunde noch Zeit gebraucht. Und war dann wirklich erst so am Ende der Rückrunde wieder so, dass ich sage, jetzt könnte ich irgendjemandem weiterhelfen. Warum auch immer, ich weiß nicht. Das hat mich so geschwächt, diese Bakteriengeschichte, dass ich wirklich nicht sagen konnte. Ich habe immer versucht, alles zu geben, aber irgendwie war nicht mehr drin.
Du warst nur einmal im Kader gestanden beim Auswärtsspiel bei Eintracht Frankfurt. War das auch tatsächlich dann die einzige Reise mit zu einem Erstligaspiel, den du mitgemacht hast in dem Jahr?
Das war mega bitter. Das war so frustrierend und ich habe mich da auch so ein bisschen reingesteigert nachher. Ich dachte auch, das kann doch nicht sein. Das hast du mitgeholfen aufzusteigen und kannst diese Früchte quasi nicht ernten.
Was macht man da, wohin mit dem Frust?
Ich habe dann versucht, in der zweiten Mannschaft Gas zu geben und mich da wieder zu empfehlen. Ich habe da auch ganz ordentlich gespielt. Dann im nächsten Jahr, wo ich dachte, okay, jetzt geht es wieder los, Vorbereitung neu. War da nicht so, wie ich es mir vorgestellt habe. Ich habe da nicht so gut performt, dass ich sagen musste, der Trainer muss mich wieder spielen lassen. Dann war es wieder erste Liga, wir sind drin geblieben, relativ souverän, glaube ich, sogar am ersten Jahr, also gut. Dann wurde, glaube ich, Patrick Sandler schon nach zehn oder neun Spielen gefeuert, mein Förderer. Dann habe ich endgültig alle Fälle davon schwimmen sehen. Dann kam Bojan Prasniká, Slowene, das war schon eine Zeit, auch für Energie Cottbus, glaube ich. Der hat uns nachher gerettet in dem Jahr, aber wir hatten, ich glaube, 15 Leute, die Balkansprache gesprochen haben, also die können natürlich alle irgendwie sich untereinander, die waren nicht alle aus einem Land, aber Mazedonien, Kroatien, Serbien, Bosnien. Wir hatten unheimlich viele, wie wir immer gesagt haben, Jugos damals und das war halt grässlich wirklich. Also der Bojan Prasniká hat die Ansprache erst in jugoslawisch oder in welcher Sprache da auch immer gemacht und kurz auf Deutsch nachher hinterher für die drei Deutschen, die wir da noch hatten und das war grässlich wirklich. Also der war so auch so eine Art Tiktator, also kam ich gar nicht mit klar und als junger Spieler war es wirklich sehr, sehr schwer. Und das war dann auch so die Zeit, wo ich gedacht habe, ja, wenn der jetzt hier bleibt und der hat ja uns nachher gerettet wirklich noch, da kann es nicht hier bleiben. Das geht nicht, ihr Versauerstes.
Freut man sich dann da drüber?
Dass die drinnen geblieben sind? Ja, na klar, das ist mein Heimatfeind. Also ich werde immer für Cottbus, ich werde immer dankbar sein, dass sie mir überhaupt die Plattform geboten haben, da spielen zu dürfen. Und deswegen habe ich mich natürlich gefreut, dass für die Region das unheimlich wichtig ist, weil da ist nicht viel. Da sind 20 Kilometer nach Polen und ein bisschen nach Berlin. Und das war es dann auch. Also da ist nicht viel. Und wenn dann erst Liga-Fußball ist, dann ist das natürlich…
Das ist nie gut für einen Ort, wenn man ihn charakterisiert, mit den Entfernungsangaben zu interessieren.
Ich meine, für mich war das damals völlig okay. Ich bin ja da aus der Gegend gewesen. Aber du hattest natürlich nicht das Fund, die Spieler zu holen, weil die dann gesagt haben, was ist denn da, da ist ja gar nichts. Wir hatten dann so Leute wie Erwin Skeller und wen hat man noch? Vlad Montejano ist dann gekommen, das sind dann die zwei Rumänen, sind dann irgendwann zu Würzburg gegangen, weil die dann relativ gut waren. Wir hatten schon ordentliche Spieler, aber wie gesagt, alles ausländische Spieler. Da hat sich gar keiner getraut, mal auf junge Deutsche zu setzen. Das war dann halt wirklich schwer und ich habe dann gesagt, das geht nicht. Wir sind dann auch im Jahr davor, glaube ich, mit der zweiten Mannschaft in die Regionalliga aufgestiegen. Das war dann dieses Qualifikationsjahr für die dritte Liga, für die Eingleisige. Da habe ich eigentlich auch relativ gut gespielt, muss ich sagen. Ich glaube, ich habe da 7 oder 8 Tore gemacht in dem Jahr und hatte dann natürlich gute Möglichkeiten, da in diese Eingleisige dritte Liga zu gehen. Das war dann für mich auch das Ziel. Ich habe dann gesagt, ich habe da jetzt 7 oder 8 Tore gemacht, also kann ich da auch ganz bequem in der dritten Liga spielen. Ich konnte mir dann quasi mit dem Jahr, das ich gespielt habe, fast aussuchen, wo ich da hingehe in der dritten Liga.
Wie läuft das? Kriegt man, bzw. dein Berater ja, kriegt man da am laufenden Band immer mal wieder Angebote oder ist es auch so, dass man sich da positioniert, also dein Berater da mal ein paar Anrufe tätigt?
Ja, das ist natürlich die perfekte Position für den Berater, wenn man gut gespielt hat und quasi warten kann auf die Anrufe. Das war dann relativ einfach, weil ich da wirklich gut gespielt hatte als junger Spieler. Da haben die Leute dann gesehen, aha, der ist wieder da jetzt, mit dem kann man wieder rechnen nach diesem Jahr, wo ich komplett raus war. Und ja, da ging es eigentlich relativ von allein, muss ich sagen. Also, Cottbus hat natürlich versucht, mich zu halten. Also, die haben dann gesagt, hey, die haben dann natürlich gesehen, ich bin wieder auf dem Weg zur alten Stärke und wollten unbedingt, dass ich bleibe. Und das war dann halt diese Situation im Nachhinein. Da ist dann irgendwann Pele Wollitz gekommen und nach Bojan Prasnikar. Da ist Cottbus dann abgestiegen in dem Jahr, in dem ich gegangen bin. Und dann kam Pele Wollitz und der hat natürlich brutal auf junge Leute gesetzt. Und da kam einer nach dem anderen von unten nach oben. Bittenkurt, Arne Feig, die haben dann natürlich alle – Alex Bittorf und Clemens Vandrich – die haben dann natürlich alle Chancen ohne Ende gekriegt. Und ich saß im Paderborn und da lief es jetzt auch nicht so optimal, ehrlich gesagt. Und ich dachte natürlich, das wäre deine Chance gewesen eventuell.
Wie kam es denn zu dem Wechsel nach Paderborn?
Nach Paderborn ging es dann halt darum, Düsseldorf war wirklich hoch im Gespräch damals. Ich hatte mich dann so Düsseldorf, Dresden, Paderborn so ein bisschen. Und habe dann wirklich hin und her überlegt. Paderborn war halt so eine Mannschaft, wo ich dann gemerkt habe, die haben die besten Spieler dieser Liga, wo ich gespielt habe davor, diese Regionalliga Nordost. Die haben die zusammengeholt und haben gesagt, wir starten den kompletten Angriff auf den Aufstieg. Und Pavel Dotschev, mit dem hatte ich mich dann in Berlin zweitmal getroffen, war super überzeugt von ihm, hat mir richtig gut gefallen. Mein Berater war dann in Berlin zusammengesessen und mein Berater hat auch gesagt, super Typ, ehrlich. So kam es dann dazu, dass ich mich relativ schnell für Paderborn entschieden habe. Ich war dann auch komplett damit zufrieden, also bin dann dahin, die Vorbereitung war eigentlich auch top. Wir hatten natürlich dem geschuldet, dass wir aufsteigen wollen, auch eine relativ starke Mannschaft auf relativ großem Konkurrenzkampf. Er hat sich dann am ersten Spieltag für den Sören Haifa entschieden, da hat er schon Bundesliga gespielt mit Hannover. Er war dann schon ein alt Paderborner, also war in dem Jahr davor da. Das war halt so ein bisschen auch der Genickbruch, glaube ich. Wenn ich da von Anfang an gespielt hätte, dann wäre das eine andere Sache gewesen. Aber so hat sich mein Startelfdebüt oder überhaupt mein Einsatzdebüt, dann hat sich auf den 8. oder 9. oder 10. Spieltag bei Union Berlin – und wie es der Zufall so will, haben wir da geführt 2-1 in Berlin. Dann kriegt Union eine rote Karte und der Trainer ruft mich. Na klar, rein und wir verlieren noch gegen 10 Mann 3-2. So hat mein Paderborn-Debüt quasi ausgesehen. Das war natürlich kein guter Start, obwohl ich jetzt nicht sage, dass das an mir gelegen hat. Aber es ist natürlich immer nicht gut, wenn du reinkommst und man verliert dann. Dann hat es noch eine Weile gedauert, dann habe ich von Anfang an gespielt und war eigentlich auch in Ordnung. Aber ich glaube, im ganzen Jahr, im Aufstiegsjahr habe ich 14 Spiele gemacht. Wenige von Anfang an, vielleicht 10 von Anfang an.
14, genau. Und noch vier im Westfalen-Pokal, ist die Frage.
Legendär im Westfalen-Pokal.
Da werden wir jetzt noch die nächste Stunde darüber sprechen.
Ja, das ist in der dritten Liga immer so, dass du diese Landespokale spielen musst, um dich dann für einen DFB-Pokal zu qualifizieren. Oder du gehst halt unter die ersten vier und bist dann sicher dabei. Und da sind wir dann auch glorreich ausgeschieden, irgendwann mit Vardabond in Münster. Und das hat sich einfach nicht so gut angefühlt. Ich habe mich da nicht so locker gefühlt. Das hat einfach nicht gepasst, muss ich sagen. Obwohl, die Mannschaft war super, ich habe noch richtig viele Freunde. Wir sind auch alle Spieler, die damals geholt wurden.
Und das waren ja viele, das waren 18 Neuzugänge.
Wir waren eine komplett neue Mannschaft quasi.
Gibt einem das im positiven oder negativen nicht zu denken, wenn man zu so einem Verein geht? Das war generell so eine Phase, wo Vardabond in ein paar Jahren aufeinander folgen, immer sehr, sehr viele Neuzugänge und sehr, sehr viele Spiele wieder abgegeben hat. Also fast wie ein Durchlauferhitzer, wobei man nicht sagen kann, weil manchen nicht auch eher ein Erkaltter war von der Karriereplanung. Gibt einem das zu denken, wenn man zu so einem Verein wechselt?
Da habe ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht drüber nachgedacht, weil ich war so darauf besessen, den Trainer zu mögen, weil ich mit Prasnikov wirklich so eine schlechte Erfahrung gemacht habe. Und Paul Deutschhoff hat einen super Eindruck auf mich gemacht. Ich war richtig überzeugt von ihm als Trainer und auch davon, dass ich bei ihm mich weiterentwickeln werde. Und deswegen habe ich da jetzt ehrlich gesagt, ich wusste, die wollen natürlich aufsteigen und ich wusste, wir werden eine gute Mannschaft haben. Aber das war jetzt eher sekundär, dass ich mir darüber Gedanken gemacht habe, ob da jetzt 18 neue Spieler sind oder nicht. Ich sagte, wir waren gute Spieler, das würde schon irgendwie klappen, habe ich mir gedacht. Es hat ja auch im Endeffekt geklappt, bloß größtenteils ohne mich leider. Wie gesagt, alle Spieler aus dieser Mannschaft sind jetzt gestandene Zweitligaspieler geworden. Also die Zusammenstellung der Mannschaft, da muss man ihm Respekt dafür zollen für die Babel-Deutschaft, da ist jetzt kaum einer, der in der Versenkung verschwunden ist. Alle sind irgendwie gute Spieler geworden in ihrem Segment. Deswegen war es privat wirklich super, ich habe da auch meine Frau kennengelernt in der Palabar-Bornzeit, meine Ehefrau. Das war dann im Endeffekt das Beste, was ich mitgenommen habe, meine Frau und die ganzen Freundschaften zu den Jungs, die heute noch bestehen. Aber wie gesagt, im zweiten Jahr, Gott sei Dank, versuche ich immer noch aus meinem Leben zu streichen. Das war Wahnsinn, dass André Schubert am Ende der Aufstiegssaison, weil man nicht mehr gedacht hatte, dass Paul Deutsch auf das hin kriegt. Das hat von Anfang an zwischen uns gar nicht gepasst. Wir sind dann aufgestiegen und die Vorbereitung war eigentlich ganz okay, wie ich fand. Aber am Ende der Vorbereitung hat André Schubert gesagt, das war schon Mitte August, dass es jetzt für dich schwer wird, dass es echt schwer wird. Wenn du etwas anderes findest, dann mach mal. Dann war es relativ spät im Transferzeitraum. Ich habe dann natürlich nichts Akkurates mehr gefunden, wo ich jetzt unüberzeugt war. Dann dachte ich, okay, ein halbes Jahr bis zum Winter musst du irgendwie durchhalten. Du trainierst halt und so. Ich hatte damals auch eine Freundin mit nach Paderborn gebracht, die ein Kind hatte, aus vorheriger Beziehung. Das hatte sich dann in dem Sommer auch gegessen. Sie ging wieder zurück in Richtung alte Heimat, wo ich sie kennengelernt hatte. Dann war ich alleine und das war das erste Mal, dass ich meine Freiheit genossen habe. Ich habe gewusst, dass ich gar keine Rolle spiele. Ich war nie im Kader, ich war so weit weg davon. Ich war da wirklich viel unterwegs in Paderborn. Im Nachhinein war es irgendwie sinnlos. Es war ein ganz verschenktes Jahr. Ein Jahr, das ich komplett hergeschenkt habe oder was im Winter hergeschenkt wurde, gab es dann Kontakt zu Dynamo. Matthias Maugsch war der Trainer, der relativ verbissen und unbedingt wollte. Die hatten aber leider kein Geld mehr, noch einen zusätzlichen Spieler. Das ging dann wirklich bis zum letzten Tag. Er hat immer gesagt, er hoffe, wir können dich noch irgendwie finanzieren, extern oder so. Das hat aber leider nicht mehr geklappt. Dann dachte ich wieder, oh Gott, jetzt noch ein halbes Jahr bis zum Sommer. Ohne Spiel, ohne alles. Paderborn zweite Mannschaft war Westfalen Liga. Das war wirklich grausam. Das war echt grausam.
Aber vom Sportlichen abgesehen hast du gesagt, du hast viele tolle Menschen kennengelernt, die dir jetzt noch verbunden geblieben sind. Wer waren denn da die wichtigsten Leute für dich in der Mannschaft? Weil wenn man die Namen durchgeht, da waren ja wirklich viele tolle Spiele mit dabei.
Also Sören Brandi habe ich heute noch, super Kontakt. Sören Gonta auch noch, super Kontakt. Florian Mohr ist noch einer meiner besten Kumpels, der letztes Jahr aufgehört hat. Und sonst, alle nette Stackefuß spielt jetzt bei Sandhausen. Also zig Leute, die da wirklich wirklich noch richtig guten Kontakt haben. Und die haben mir wirklich auch geholfen, die Freundschaft zu dehnen. Serjan Givinisek hatten wir noch im Sturm. Domi Kumbela hatten wir, wir hatten wirklich Björn Lindemann. Also wir hatten wirklich einen riesen Kicker damals für die dritte Liga, die auch alle irgendwie funktionierte, am Rolf-Kristel Gimian aus Köln, alte Fuchs. Ines Alushi, genau. Also wir hatten wirklich eine gute Mannschaft, muss man sagen. Und da dieser Bund, den wir hatten als Mannschaft, das war wirklich auch recht einzigartig, muss ich sagen, wie wir zusammengehalten haben und wie wir als Kumpels füreinander da waren, war echt cool auch. Ich hatte da auch nie das Gefühl, dass die Jungs mich jetzt als einen gesehen haben, der jetzt nie spielt oder so. Das war nie das Thema oder so. Wir waren immer, das war echt top. Also muss ich echt sagen, das war relativ einzigartig.
Hat man dann in so einer Phase Motivationsprobleme? Weil du musst dich ja im Training, ich stelle mir Training nicht immer angenehm vor, weil du musst dich da ja quälen, du hast ja nicht jeden Tag Bock drauf. Und ja, Training nervt einfach in erster Linie erstmal.
Naja, es war halt so, dass es mein einziges Ding war, wo ich fit sein bleiben konnte. Also wusste ich, ich musste Gas geben und ich war auch immer gut drauf. Und ich wusste, André Schubert, der hat dann natürlich immer versucht, mich loszuwerden. Und hätte mich auch wahrscheinlich gerne in die zweite gesteckt. Aber das ging natürlich nicht, weil die nur Westfalen Liga gespielt haben. Und du ja dann einen gewissen Trainingsstandard haben musst, wenn du irgendwie abgeschoben wirst. Und ich weiß auch, dass er sich im Nachhinein darüber immer aufgeregt hat, dass ich immer noch so gut drauf war. Also er hat nicht aufgeregt, aber er hat sich gewundert, warum ich immer… Ich habe halt immer Vollgas gegeben im Training. Ich habe immer versucht, das Beste daraus zu machen und nie schlecht drauf zu sein. Weil die Jungs können ja am Endeffekt auch nicht zerführen. Also das war wirklich nur ein Ding zwischen Trainer und mir quasi. Und deswegen hat er sich da, glaube ich… Ich habe es im Nachhinein noch ein paar Mal gehört, dass er sich gewundert hat, wie gut ich immer drauf war, trotzdem die Situation so schlecht war. Und klar, es sind manchmal Motivationsprobleme. Aber es war halt die einzige Situation, wo ich irgendwie fit bleiben konnte und wo ich irgendwie sagen konnte, ich muss ja im Rhythmus bleiben irgendwie. Weil dann kommt eine Aufgabe und dann musst du da sein im neuen Jahr. Das war dann relativ klar, relativ zeitig schon. Da habe ich dann meine Wohnung relativ im März oder im Februar schon gekündigt, so dass ich wusste, hier geht es sicher nicht weiter, das ist ja klar.
Aber es ist schon eine besondere Beziehung, die man da mit seinen Trainern hat. Vor allem du hattest ja jetzt allein jetzt schon – wir sind ja noch lange nicht im Jahr 2017 angekommen – aber schon jetzt hattest du ein paar Beispiele, wo du sagst, da hat es einfach nicht gepasst. Und da war dir dann auch sehr schnell und sehr früh klar, das wird auch nicht passen.
Und da würde ich jetzt auch wirklich bei Andries Schubert differenzieren, weil der ist echt sonst ein guter Trainer, wie ich finde. Also er hat unfassbares Fachwissen und unfassbare Akribie im Fußball. Aber es hat einfach menschlich zwischen uns gar nicht gepasst. Also wir haben gar nicht zusammengefunden, beide haben gar keine Basis gefunden. Und im Nachhinein ist es auch irgendwie okay so. Also ich habe jetzt natürlich nicht die besten Gedanken, wenn ich an ihn denke. Aber es ist nun mal so, du kannst nicht mit jedem Grün sein. Und das habe ich dann auch gelernt, das einfach irgendwie auch zu akzeptieren im Endeffekt. Und das hat mir dann auch mit den weiteren Trainern ein bisschen geholfen, dass ich gemerkt habe, manchmal musst du halt auch nicht… Es ist natürlich immer schön, wenn dir der Trainer vertraut, dann bist du wahrscheinlich auch eher in der Lage, deine Leistung zu bringen. Aber man musste dann auch lernen, bei einem Trainer trotzdem gut zu sein, auch wenn das Verhältnis irgendwie dann nicht das Beste war, was dann später vielleicht auch nochmal so war. Und wo ich aber gelernt habe, du musst trotzdem mehr Leistung abliefern.
Und lässt sich das nicht voneinander trennen oder müsste man das nicht… Ich will jetzt auch gar nicht nur konkret auf André Schubert einhaken, sondern generell bei Trainer müsste man nicht eigentlich erwarten, dass die das trennen können, ob sie menschlich mit jemandem können und ob er ihn sportlich weiterbringt. Ich würde davon ausgehen, dass Pep Guardiola mit Franck Ribery nie um die Häuser gezogen ist.
Ja, ich meine, wenn du jetzt André Schubert fragen würdest, würde er natürlich auch sagen, dass ich halt sportlich nicht gepasst habe. Ich glaube nicht, dass er jetzt nur aufs Menschliche das gemacht hat. Also würde ich jetzt sicher sagen, dass er das sagt. Wahrscheinlich, wenn du ihn damals gefragt hättest, hätte er auch gesagt, das wird nichts mehr mit ihm. Also das reicht einfach nicht vielleicht.
Das ist natürlich das richtige Argument.
Das würde der jetzt hundertprozentig sagen.
Dann ist es eine Kombination aus beiden. Na gut, schließen wir das Kapitel Paderborn. Wie ging es dann für dich weiter?
Dann war Matthias Maugsch wieder unheimlich emsig am Telefon. Also ich war so oft telefoniert. Und ich bin dann erstmal mit Flo Mohr, weiß ich noch, und Sajan Gewinnysek in die Staaten geflogen. Urlaub ganz normal, ohne dass ich ihn vereinnerte. Da hatte ich ein bisschen ein mulmiges Gefühl. Ich dachte so, ich wollte mir aber auch Zeit lassen, weil ich wusste, wenn es jetzt nicht funktioniert im nächsten Verein, dann wird es eng. Also dann musst du dir vielleicht überlegen, ob das mit Fußball noch Sinn macht.
Was hat dein Berater gesagt? Hat er auch gesagt, fahr in den Urlaub, krieg den Kopf frei? Oder hat er gesagt, bleib mal lieber hier, bitte?
Da hat er gesagt, fahr ruhig, wir können alles über Fax und Telefon sowieso regeln.
Moment mal, welches Jahr war das? Das war doch 2008, oder?
2008, ja, da kam gerade das iPhone und so raus. Ich glaube, ich hatte es auch schon. Also, da ging das so los, dass man…
Beim Wort Fax bin ich nur irgendwie.
Ja, das ging. Er hat gesagt, mach dir keine Gedanken, du bist auch schnell wieder hier. Wenn was ist, bist du in zwölf Stunden wieder hier und dann können wir das auch noch klären. So war es dann auch im Endeffekt. Es war natürlich nicht viel, was ich hatte. Ich hatte so etwas wie Erfurt, Dynamo und ich weiß gar nicht, was noch war. Nicht viel, wirklich nicht viel. Matthias Maugsch hat mich jeden Tag angerufen und hat gesagt, und was machen wir jetzt? Weißt du schon, wir wollen dich unbedingt. Ich weiß, du hattest jetzt nicht die besten Jahre, aber ich setze auf dich. Das war so ein Ding, wo ich gesagt habe, Dresden ist nah an meiner Heimat gewesen, so 50 Kilometer, meine Heimat war genau zwischen Dresden und Cottbus, also beiderseits 50 Kilometer ungefähr. Ich dachte, das ist jetzt das Beste, ich bin wieder bei meiner Familie in der Nähe und habe da diesen Rückhalt, den ich brauche und anscheinend einen Trainer, der auf mich setzen wird. Da war ich mir relativ dynamo und natürlich ein geiler Vereiner. Obwohl ich so nah an Dresden gewohnt habe, hatte ich nie einen Bezug als Kind zu Dynamo. Ich weiß nicht warum, ich habe mich das im Nachhinein irgendwann gefragt, aber die Nähe zu Cottbus war irgendwie immer…
Vielleicht bergst du durch deinen Vater, oder?
Vielleicht, aber mein Vater hat eigentlich auch weder für Dresden noch für Cottbus gespielt.
Stimmt, er hat auch bei Senfenberg gespielt.
Aber es war halt Brandenburg und Dresden war Sachsen quasi in dem Moment. Und deswegen war Cottbus dann halt auch von… Weil das das Einzugsgebiet war, war Brandenburg von der Schule von Cottbus. Und deswegen bin ich auch nie mit Dynamo in Berührung gekommen. Cottbus hatte damals das weit, weit bessere Nachwuchskonzept. Und auch die Bedingungen waren weitaus besser. Deswegen war das damals nie so. Und im Nachhinein jetzt dachte ich mir, Dresden ist doch irgendwie ein geiler Verein und die haben das Stadion neu gebaut. Das war gerade fertig geworden. Und da hatte ich dann richtig Bock drauf, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Und dann war es so, war natürlich was ganz anderes von Palabon. Die Medienpräsenz allein in Dresden war natürlich Wahnsinn. Also ich habe das direkt am ersten Laktatest gemerkt. Gott, da standen zehn Leute, vier verschiedene Zeitungen. Das war natürlich noch mal was ganz anderes als Cottbus damals. Das kannte ich in dem Moment auch nicht. Und es war damals die dritte Liga. Und da war ein Rummel. Ich dachte, das ist ja Wahnsinn hier, wirklich. Also es war schon eine Hausnummer. Und da dachte ich schon, okay, das könnte Spaß machen, hier zu spielen. Das könnte Bock machen. Und so war es dann eigentlich auch. Die Vorbereitungen waren in Ordnung. Das erste Spiel haben wir zwar verloren, 2-1 in Braunschweig weiß ich noch. Und im zweiten Spiel war ich natürlich zwischendurch unter der Woche krank und habe nicht trainiert. Und dann hat der Trainer gesagt, es ist mir zu heiß. Ich bringe dich von der Bank gegen Jena zu Hause. Und dann bin ich dann reingekommen. Klassiker, Ball springt hoch, ich gehe zum Kopfball, einer buggelt mich auf. Ich falle komplett mit dem Kopf und der Schulter in den Boden rein. Und unfassbarer Schmerz zuerst. Und ich dachte, da habe ich so ein bisschen versucht. Da ging es einigermaßen. Da habe ich weiter gespielt. Und dann gab es noch so eine Situation, wo ich eine Riesentorschance hatte und ich schieße. Und ich mache immer so eine Art Bewegung beim Schießen so zurück. Und dann hat alles zerstört. Also ich glaube, wenn da was noch nicht kaputt war, dann war es danach kaputt in der Schulter. Und dann waren die Schmerzen auch so groß, dass ich nicht mehr weiterspielen konnte. Raus ins Krankenhaus und Schulter, Ecke, Längssprengung.
Die alten Beckenbauer-Verletzungen.
Höchsten Grades, also wirklich alles kaputt, was drin war. Und dann dachte ich, der Fußballgott meint es mit mir jetzt auch nicht wirklich so gut. Und am Ende muss man sagen, toll, toll, toll, meine letzte Verletzung seither.
Schwebt es immer so ein bisschen mit? Du bist ja auch sehr schnell danach wieder zurückgekommen. Also das hat mich gewundert. Du hast nur sieben Spiele verpasst und das mit so einer gravierenden Verletzung.
Da war ich selbst überrascht, ehrlich gesagt.
Genau, und nicht so wie damals bei Meniskus, wo sich dann im Nachhinein rausgestellt hat, ah ja, ging doch nicht nach zwei Wochen weg. Aber schwebt es immer so ein bisschen mit, wenn man Profifußballer ist, diese Verletzungsgefahr und die Angst, dass die eine Grätsche kommt, die halt irgendwie das Licht ausknipst?
Na ja, damals eigentlich auch überhaupt nicht. Aber durch diese negativen Erfahrungen, die ich da gemacht habe, war es natürlich dann allgegenwärtig irgendwie in dem Moment. Als junger Kerl habe ich mir da nicht so große Gedanken drüber gemacht, aber dann natürlich immer mehr. Aber dann habe ich zumindest mal die schnelle Seite der Genesung kennengelernt, dass das auch mal deutlich schneller ist. Die Ärzte hatten eigentlich gesagt, drei Monate Pause, locker, haben die gesagt.
Dann warst du letztlich eigentlich nur den Oktober verletzt. Den August, den September, Entschuldigung. Wir sind übrigens im Jahr 2010 – ich glaube, ich habe 2008 vorhin gesagt. Das war natürlich Quatsch. Ja, 2010, genau.
Das ging relativ schnell und dann war ich auch relativ schnell wieder gut drauf, muss ich sagen. Das hat dann nicht so lange gedauert. Und dann ging es irgendwann los. Dann habe ich dann ein paar Spiele gemacht. Wir waren so lala, waren immer so im Mittelfeld, oberes Mittelfeld, aber jetzt nicht irgendwie Aufstiegsambition. Wir hatten aber trotzdem gute Spieler. Wir hatten damals Christian Fiel geholt als erfahrenen Typen. Und Alex Eswein als junges Juwel, Danny Shahin hatten wir noch. Das waren unsere drei Topspieler, die wir in dem Jahr hatten. Wir hatten auch eine geile Truppe. Du brauchst eine geile Truppe, um aufzusteigen. Das ist auch klar, du brauchst eine gute Chemie. Aber der Matthias Mauchsch hat es damals gut verstanden, die Truppe zusammenzustellen. Wir hatten auch ein gutes Gemisch zwischen Jung und Alt. Dann kam es irgendwann dazu, dass er mit dem Linksverteidiger nicht so richtig zufrieden war. Da hat er mich dann auch immer rumgeschubst, hat mich dann auf der Sechs spielen lassen manchmal. Da habe ich links außen gespielt. Man hat immer gemerkt, dass er mich reindrücken wollte, aber er wusste nicht so richtig, wo ich wohne. Ich bin dann immer so gesprungen für ein paar Spieler. Irgendwann hat er gefragt, ob ich auch links Verteidiger spielen kann, ob ich das hinbekomme. Dann habe ich gesagt, klar.
Hat da jemals schon mal jemand Nein gesagt auf so eine Frage?
Nicht wirklich. Bei manchen Sachen wäre es vielleicht auch besser gewesen, aber da wusste ich natürlich sicher, dass ich das hinbekomme. Das habe ich schon davor mal gespielt gehabt, mehr oder weniger. Das habe ich hinbekommen und das hat von dem an super funktioniert. Ich glaube, in Skyrim war er selbst nicht so richtig überzeugt davon, aber er war die einzige Option, die im Kader noch war. Das hat von da an überragend funktioniert. Ich habe da wenig schwache Spiele gemacht, sondern er wurde immer stärker auf der Position und habe dann auch zum Schluss die Tore gemacht, die uns beflügelt hatten, Dritter zu werden. Ich glaube, in den letzten zwei Spielen habe ich nochmals zwei Tore gemacht. Zuhause gegen Burghausen, 11 Meter, wo alle dachten, es war, es nehme sich den Ball, Fjell nimmt sich den Ball. Nein, da habe ich mir den Ball genommen.
Warum denn eigentlich? Du hast später – das kann ich schon mal vorausschicken – bei fünf Elfmeterschießen im DFB-Pokal auf dem Platz gestanden. Du bist kein einziges Mal angetreten, da hätte ich dich eh noch nachgefragt. Aber am 37. Spieltag gegen Burghausen?
Wir hatten davor im Training – wir haben jetzt ein bisschen übersprungen, der Matthias Maugsch. Wir hatten dann mal sechs Spiele hintereinander gewonnen mit Matthias Maugsch und haben dann einmal unentschieden gespielt, glaube ich, und haben dann dreimal hintereinander verloren. Aus irgendwelchen Gründen war dann das Vertrauen in ihn gar nicht mehr da. Das war eine ganz komische Situation. Wir waren da auch nicht einverstanden, weil wir ihn eigentlich super gemocht haben, den Trainer, und wir eigentlich auch dachten, dass das nur eine Momentaufnahme war. Aber der Verein hat dann natürlich gerochen und gesehen, da ist was möglich dieses Jahr, wir können aufsteigen, und die wollten halt nichts dem Zufall überlassen. Und dann war er weg leider, und wir standen da. Und dann war die Frage, wer wird neuer Trainer? Und bei so einem Verein wie Dresden war das natürlich ein Riesenspektakel. Die haben da alle möglichen Namen wieder reingeschmissen, die Star in der Dixie Dörner und blablabla und wer da alles genannt wurde. Und dann war Ralf Lohse. Und wir haben uns alle gefragt, wer ist das? Wer ist das? Ralf Lohse. Keiner konnte sich einen Reim drauf bilden. Und glücklicherweise war es genau der Typ, den wir irgendwie gebraucht hatten in der Situation. Weil der hatte absolute Ruhe und der hatte so ein Urvertrauen in uns, dass wir dann mit ihm, glaube ich, kein Spiel mehr verloren haben bis zum Schluss. Also wir haben dann zu Hause gegen Koblenz gewonnen, in Bremen gewonnen. Und dann kam es das ominöse Spiel, wenn jetzt Dynamo-Fans zuhören, in Babelsberg, wo wir eigentlich alles richtig gemacht haben und auf dem besten Weg waren, das Spiel zu gewinnen. Und am Ende, wenn sie zum gerüchten Tor gekriegt haben, wirklich unfassbar alle am Boden zerstört. Und das war aber genau der Punkt, der uns dann auf dem dritten Platz gehievt hat, weil alle verloren hatten um uns herum. Und wir waren auf einmal dritter, drei oder vier Spieltage vor Schluss.
Ja, das war der dritte Spieltag vor Schluss, und dann gab es noch zwei Spiele, die wir zu spielen hatten.
Und wir wussten, wir müssen beide gewinnen, dann sind wir dritter. Dann sind wir einfach dritter.
Das gemacht gegen Wackerburg-Hausen zu Hause 2-0 mit dem Elfmeter von dir. Und dann auswärts bei den Kickers Offenbach.
Was ein super schweres Spiel war wirklich. Alle anderen hatten ein relativ leichtes Spiel. Ich glaube, Wien Wiesbaden war einer unserer Konkurrenten, die hatten in Bremen zwei Spiele, wo relativ klar war, dass die gewinnen werden. Das war natürlich ein super schweres Spiel am Biberer Berg. Die waren auch relativ lange im Aufstiegsrennen. Dann mussten sie irgendwann abreißen lassen. So war das Spiel auch wirklich. Wahnsinn. Das eigene Tor vom Fiello war am Boden zerstört. Dann kommt, glaube ich, Danny Schar hin und macht zum Schluss das Tor. Und wir gewinnen 3-2. Unfassbar, was man allgemein dazu sagen muss. Die Stimmung im Stadion für eine Drittliga war Wahnsinn. Das hatte ich davor so noch nie erlebt, vor allem nicht in einer dritten Liga. Man hat einfach gemerkt, umso besser wir wurden als die Fans. Wenn du in Dresden einigermaßen Erfolg hast, dann tragen die dich mit Händen durch die Stadt. Da erkennt dich auch die Oma mit dem Krückstock, die 95-Jährige, die dann dir vorbeiläuft und sagt, du hast es super gemacht in Dresden. Das ist wahnsinnige Euphorie, was da abgeht und Wahnsinniger Fanatismus. Die ganze Stadt, da erkennt dich wirklich jeder. Ich glaube, wie gesagt, dass auch Frank Ribery mehr in München erkannt wurde als ein guter Spieler in Dresden. Da ist nur Fußball, das ist Religion an Dresden. Das ist auch so geil. Deswegen war das das erste Jahr. Das war einfach nur herrlich, weil diese ganzen schlechten Jahre, die ich da hatte, das hat sich so gut angefühlt. Unfassbar.
Gewinnt man da – es war ja auch ein neues Stadion, hast du schon angesprochen – gewinnt man da manche Spiele auch wirklich mit den Zuschauern? Oder ist das so ein Mythos, den Zuschauer wie ich mir gerne einrede?
Also mit Dresden haben wir Spiele einfach nur gewonnen, weil sich der Gegner auch in die Hose gemacht hat vor dem Spiel. Wir sind rausgekommen, also eingelaufen zum Spiel dann quasi. Und dann hast du die in den K-Block gesehen, die Wand. Unfassbar, die haben Stimmung gemacht. Die haben das Dynamo-Lied davor gesungen, Gänsehaut am ganzen Körper, immer, wenn es kam. Und wir haben wirklich Spiele teilweise nur gewonnen, weil sich die Gegner in die Hosen gemacht haben. Also wirklich, weil da, wenn wir da mal selbst aus dem Nichts, wir waren schlecht erst der Halbzeit, haben aus dem Nichts mal zwei, drei Eckbälle erzwungen oder irgendeiner wurde über die Bande gerätscht, dann waren die da und waren so laut und das hat dem Gegner wirklich so oft Respekt eingehaucht. Das ist also großer Faktor, ohne die wären wir damals – und das soll jetzt nicht so platt klingen oder so, aber ohne die wären wir nicht aufgestiegen, das hat nichts mit Schleimerei zu tun oder so, aber ohne die wäre das nicht möglich gewesen. Auch in den Relegationsspielen nachher.
Ja, da muss ich sowieso mit dir noch darüber sprechen, warum du so ein besonderes Verhältnis zu einer Stadt hast.
Im Nachhinein war ich immer gesperrt. Ich war da auf dem Bach, weiß ich noch. Ich weiß nicht, warum, das ist aus mir rausgeplätschert, wie ich habe geheult, wie ein kleines Kind auf dem Platz. Ich war so froh, Teil dieser Mannschaft zu sein und immer gespielt zu haben nach den Jahren, die ich davor mitgemacht habe. Und dann habe ich meine fünfte Gelbe in dem Spiel gekriegt. Und das hieß dann gesperrt in dem Spiel.
Genau, in der Relegation dann gegen Osnabrück. Du hast gegen Osnabrück insgesamt dreimal Relegation gespielt. Einmal kann man so ein bisschen ausklammern, weil das eine Mal war mit Paderborn. Und dann zweimal mit Dresden und nie verloren. Also Otto Rehagel wird ja in Griechenland, glaube ich, immer noch eingeladen, egal in welches Restaurant er geht. Ich glaube, in Osnabrück dürftest du überall Hausverbot haben.
Anscheinend, ja, wirklich. Also es ist eine wahnsinnige Sache. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie das dann immer zustande kam. Aber es war wirklich immer aus Osnabrück, komischerweise. Und es war auch immer relativ dramatisch irgendwie auch. Aber am Ende immer der gute Ausgang für uns.
Gibt dann ja auch ein gutes Gefühl. Das ist ja fast wie, wenn Italien gegen Deutschland bei einem nationalen Turnier spielt, dann sagen die Italiener, ja war Bene, ja geil, mega gut, das wird schon laufen. Und so hat sich das doch dann wahrscheinlich für euch irgendwann auch angefühlt.
So hat sich das dann irgendwann angefühlt. Obwohl das wirklich, also wie gesagt, ich war am Boden zerstört, ich konnte nicht spielen, das Hinspiel in Dresden, obwohl ich wusste, das wird eine unfassbare Stimmung werden. Das war es dann auch. Und wir haben, glaube ich, nur 1-1 gespielt zu Hause. Hab da auf der Tribüne gesessen, Blut und Wasser geschwitzt da oben. Also wirklich ganz schrecklich, ich kannte es auch nicht wirklich. Also das ist für mich das Schlimmste, was es gibt, wenn so wichtige Spiele draußen zu sitzen. Und auf der Bank und so, alles okay, aber nicht auf der Tribüne, das ist ganz schlimm. Und im Rückspiel habe ich dann gespielt, Trainer hat mich dann wieder reingemacht, aber war ehrlich gesagt wirklich ein richtiges Kackspiel von mir, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Also erste Halbzeit war noch okay, zweite Halbzeit, boah, da hat es gebrannt auf meiner Seite, lichterloh. Und da hat mich der Trainer irgendwann befreit, glaube ich, in der 70. oder so. Und hat gesagt, komm mal runter, es ist besser heute. Ich war auch, glaube ich, ein bisschen verletzt, hatte irgendwas. Und dann hat er gesagt, komm runter, das macht heute keinen Sinn. Ich war ihm auch in gewisser Weise irgendwie dankbar, weil ich einfach, ich habe es nicht auf die Kette gekriegt an dem Tag. Es war so ein Tag, wo ich dachte, heute geht gar nichts, wirklich. Ich habe irgendwie versucht, aber es ging einfach nichts. Aber zum Glück konnte Osnabrück das irgendwie auch nicht bestrafen. Aus irgendeinem Grund, weiß ich nicht. Und die Jungs haben das dann sensationell gepackt in der Verlängerung. Kochi Fiello hat ein Tor gemacht, Kochi hat ein Tor gemacht, Danny Schahin hat, glaube ich, ein Tor gemacht. Und dann ging natürlich so eine Aufstiegsfeier mit Dynamo los. Da habe ich dann natürlich nur der reine Gedanke daran, was dann da los sein wird in der Stadt. Das hat mich erzittern lassen, wirklich. Und so war es dann im Endeffekt natürlich auch. Wir sind nachts dann, das war ja montags, glaube ich. Das Rückspiel ist am Montag oder Dienstags, glaube ich. Und wir sind mit einer Charter-Maschine zurückgeflogen von Münster-Ossner-Brück, der Flughafen, nach Dresden. Das war irgendwie drei Uhr nachts oder zwei Uhr nachts. Und da waren zigtausende am Flughafen. Das war unfassbar. Der ist so ein bisschen außerhalb von Dresden, der Flughafen. Und wir sind dann mit so einem offenen Bus, schweinekalt wirklich, also superkalt. Aber die Fans sind da einfach mitgelaufen mit uns, mit dem Bus in die Stadt. Und das war Wahnsinn. Die mussten alle wieder arbeiten morgens, aber das war denen scheißegal. Und das war für mich ungreifbar. Da wusste ich nochmal endgültig, was der Verein für die Fans bedeutet oder für die Leute da bedeutet. Und das war wirklich ein Wahnsinn, muss ich sagen, ehrlich. Und dann nächsten Tag natürlich, wir auch wieder besoffen. Natürlich viel zu früh, aber da war es mir wirklich egal, weil es war klar, dass dann am nächsten Tag erst die richtige Feier wird. Also wir waren ein paar, zwei Stunden geschlafen oder so aufgestanden. Dann haben wir uns im Stadion getroffen und sind dann mit so einem offenen Bus durch die Stadt. Das war natürlich alles nochmal größer als Cottbus. Also die haben da überall in den Fenstern gestanden und Wahnsinn. Und dann sind wir auf diesem Marktplatz, weiß nicht wie viele Zehntausende da waren. Und das war Wahnsinn. Das war das schönste Erlebnis, was man sich vorstellen konnte bei einem Aufstieg.
Dresden ist eine fußballverrückte Stadt. Du hast vorhin auch einmal das Wort Fanatismus verwendet. Und das kann man ja im Positiven wie im Negativen verwenden. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das anfangen soll. Also Dresden ist auf jeden Fall ein Verein, zu dem jeder eine Meinung hat. Das ist ja schon mal interessant, weil es gibt ganz viele Vereine. Sorry, aber wir haben gerade über Osnabrück gesprochen, da glaube ich, sagen 85 Prozent aller Fußballfans. Osnabrück, das ist für mich wie so ein weißes Sina 4-Blatt. Ist halt da, stört nicht, kann aber auch in den Schrank. Und zu Dresden hat jeder eine Meinung. Das hat natürlich ganz viel damit zu tun, dass sich der positive Fanatismus auch negativ äußert. Ich habe vorhin nochmal gegoogelt, dieses berühmte Plakat. Ihr habt 60 Minuten, um die Stadt zu verlassen, der Ultras, beim Abstieg. Das war lange nach deiner Zeit. Empfindest du denn die Berichterstattung, die jetzt überregional stattfindet, über Dynamo Dresden als fair? Denn ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, ich kriege jenseits von sozialen Medien, da konnte ich mir so ein bisschen einen Blick auf Dynamo Dresden aufbauen, der vielleicht ein bisschen tiefer ist als das, was man sonst kriegt. Aber dann kriegt man von Dynamo Dresden eigentlich meistens nur was mit, wenn irgendwas schiefgeht. Wenn es bei einer Auswärtsfahrt kracht oder wenn eine sehr martialische Aktion gegen den DFB gestartet wird, dann wird darüber berichtet, aber erst ein paar Monate später eigentlich über die Beweggründe dahinter. Wie empfindest du die überregionale Berichterstattung über Dresden?
Ich meine, wenn du jetzt Spieler warst, dann kannst du das natürlich alles nochmal differenzieren. Wir haben die ja auch kennengelernt, die Fans. Wir waren im Mannschaftsrat, haben wir uns hin und wieder mal mit den Ultras auch getroffen. Das war halt super interessant.
Gab es das vorher bei den Vereinen auch schon? Oder ist das so eine Dresdeneigenart? Ich finde es interessant, dass sich der Mannschaftsrat mit den Ultras tritt.
Ja, das war in der Form das erste Mal. Zumindest bei Cottbus habe ich es nicht mitgekriegt, weil ich natürlich gar nichts mit dem Mannschaftsrat zu tun hatte als junger Spieler. Das könnte ich jetzt gar nicht genau sagen. Bei Paderborn war die Fan-Unterstützung nicht so groß, dass man sich zusammensetzen müsste. Aber das war dann bei Dresden hin und wieder mal gang und gäbe. Es war nicht ganz regelmäßig, aber schon wieder mal.
Was haben wir da besprochen? Geht es eher darum, sich gegenseitig zu sagen, dass man sich cool findet oder dass man alles für den Verein gibt?
Gar nicht. Man hat sich natürlich öfter getroffen, wenn es gekrieselt hat. Dann wollten die natürlich immer ein bisschen Feedback haben, was der Zustand der Mannschaft ist und ob sie sich Gedanken machen müssen. Du merkst relativ schnell, dass da auch super, super viele gebildete Leute drin sind. Das ist Wahnsinn, was da auch für Menschen drin waren, wie die sich ausgedrückt haben. Das hast du in dem Sinne vielleicht am Anfang nicht erwartet. Das ist ein richtiges, wie soll ich sagen, ein richtig strenges Gebilde da. Wer da was zu sagen hat, wer nicht. Klar, das wären jetzt auch die meisten, die sich denken können, aber da sind schon richtig Leute, die richtig was auf der Tasche haben, am Werk. Und was man über die Medien hört, ist natürlich immer nur die Spitze des Eisbergs. Dynamo wird natürlich da auch gern benutzt, um was Negatives darzustellen, um die Fans als negativ darzustellen. Zu Hause zum Beispiel, außer in diesem ominösen Abstiegsspiel, wo wir 60 Minuten Zeit hatten, die Stadt zu verlassen, ist zu Hause nie was passiert. Zu Hause war immer weltklasse Stimmung. Keiner hatte Angst, ins Stadion zu gehen mit seiner Familie. Wenn du den Dresdner fragst, dann würde du das niemals sagen. In Dresden im Stadion passiert nichts, da ist alles super. Das war immer nur irgendwie auswärts. Ich glaube, das sind Leute gewesen, die nicht immer im Kern dabei sind, sondern die immer zu Auswärtsspielen dazukommen. Wo die denken, da können wir jetzt was starten. Da sind vielleicht die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen nicht so. Ich hatte immer das Gefühl, dass das so ein bisschen auch externe Leute sind. Ich weiß, ich kann es nicht genau belegen. Aber ich hatte schon das Gefühl, dass die Mehrheit der Fans da wirklich… Klar, wenn du mich fragst, die können sich auch vor dem Spiel auf einer Wiese treffen und können sich da die Köpfe einschlagen. Wenn da nur die involviert sind, die das auch wirklich machen wollen und da keiner gestört wird, dann sollen die das machen. Aber im Stadion hat es nichts zu suchen. Da hatte ich eigentlich immer das Gefühl, dass da vernünftige Leute am Werk sind. Aber du kannst eben auch nicht diese ganze Masse immer steuern. Da kannst du auch nicht immer die verantwortlich machen, weil das sind dann Einzelne, die dann aus der Situation heraus – das spielt auch Alkohol wahrscheinlich eine Rolle nachher oder eine große Rolle. Das nimmt dann immer so eine Eigendynamik an, die dann wahrscheinlich nicht so leicht aufgehalten werden kann. Deswegen ist es ein sehr, sehr, sehr schwieriges Thema, glaube ich, auch für die Dresdner Fans, weil die natürlich wie so ein gebrannt marktes Kind sind und sich dann auch relativ schnell angesucht fühlen.
Sich aber irgendwie auch immer wieder selbst brandmarken.
Wie gesagt, ich bin jetzt ja auch nicht der, der hier sagt, die müssen beschützt werden. Da gibt es sicherlich zu viele Aktionen. Im Endeffekt, wo man dann sagt, man, das geht natürlich irgendwie nicht. Aber ich möchte sagen, 80 Prozent von dem, was die machen, ist überragend. Ich weiß nicht, wenn Dresden 50.000 Zuschauer Stadion hätte, ich weiß nicht, ob es eine bessere Stimmung in Deutschland geben würde als in Sohn. In den 30.000 ist das schon immens, die Stimmung. Warst du schon mal bei einem ausverkauften Dynamo-Spiel?
Nein, leider nicht. Aber ich habe schon sehr, sehr viele Stimmungsvideos gesehen. Und es gab ja unter anderem auch die eine Choreografie, die komplett Stadion-umspannende Block-Fahne. Das ist natürlich sensationell.
Wir kommen ja gleich noch zu Spielen, wo die Stimmung nachher explodiert ist. Du verstehst nichts mehr, du hörst nur noch diese Mengen. Ich habe das Gefühl, die schreien auch lauter als alle anderen. Ich weiß nicht, warum, aber ich habe das Gefühl, die ist wahnsinnig laut und du hast so einen Respekt nachher da auch als Gegner vor. Ich habe jetzt danach auch schon ein paar Mal gespielt wieder. Das ist einfach eine Wand. Du merkst ja, die sind einfach unfassbar laut und die können einen richtigen Einfluss aufs Spiel nehmen. Natürlich, wie ich es nachher erfahren musste, können sie auch Druck auf die eigene Mannschaft ausüben mit ihrem Dasein. Aber das musst du natürlich auch in Kauf nehmen, wenn du die gute Stimmung haben willst.
Wie differenziert kannst du das als Spieler betrachten, wenn es um die eigenen Fans geht? Man muss nicht arg weit recherchieren, nicht nur um Dresden-Fans, aber wir sind jetzt am Beispiel Dresden. Wenn ich mir zum Beispiel angucke, was es für rechte Fans gibt, die mit auf Länderspielreisen fahren, gerade auch auswärts, da siehst du viele Dynamo-Dresden-Zeichen, aber auch von anderen Vereinen. Kann man das, wenn man als Spieler aktiv ist, für so einen Verein überhaupt differenziert betrachten? Weil irgendwie musst du ja trotzdem den 80 Prozent, oder wahrscheinlich sind es viel, viel mehr, die in der Kurve stehen, mit denen du auch sagen würdest, wir stimmen überein in dem, für was wir stehen und wie wir Fußball wollen und vielleicht auch für die Art der Gesellschaft, die wir wollen, nämlich tolerant und offen. Gehst du da in die Kurve und klatsch für die, oder konntest du das auch schon als Spieler irgendwie differenzierter betrachten? Ich finde es, sogar schon darüber sprechen, irgendwie schwierig. Aber es ist ein vorhandenes Problem.
Also ich habe mit Rassismus vor allen Dingen in Dresden eigentlich gar nicht so, also wenig schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht, ehrlich gesagt. Wir hatten ja auch dann viele Spieler, die dunkelhäutig waren, nachher in der zweiten Liga. Wir hatten relativ viele Franzosen. Und ich hatte immer das Gefühl, dass das wirklich in Ordnung war. Also wir wurden dann teilweise, weiß ich noch, in Chemnitz oder so, da gab es dann wirklich diese berühmten Leideraffenrufe und Bananen sind aufs Feld geflogen und so. Also das finde ich dann wirklich, das fand ich dann ekelhaft wirklich. Und das ist aber in Dresden nie so passiert. Und deswegen kann ich da auch gar nicht so viel Negatives dazu sagen, was den Bereich jetzt angeht. Du weißt natürlich, dass es da Leute gibt, die eine gewisse Gesinnung haben auf die rechte Seite. Das weißt du natürlich. Aber wenn du damit jetzt nicht so als persönlich schlechte Erfahrungen machst, dann schiebst du das vielleicht so ein bisschen für dich weg, das Thema, und sagst, ich hatte damit noch gar keine schlechten Erfahrungen. Deswegen ist es für mich jetzt gar nicht so schlimm.
Müsste sich da Fußballspieler und auch Vereine vielleicht auch noch häufiger deutlich positionieren, denn du kannst ja auf der einen Seite nicht beeinflussen, wer dich mag. Also es könnte auch sein, dass es jetzt AfD-Wähler da draußen gibt, die in den Rasenfunk hören, wo ich sagen würde, mit eurem Wettbeet stimme ich so wenig übereinander, dass ich auch nicht möchte, dass ihr Rasenfunk-Supporter werdet. Aber vielleicht indem ich sowas sage, steuere ich sie ja vielleicht auch, weil die jetzt dann, wenn es solche gibt, empört gerade ausgemacht haben vielleicht und mich für immer verdammen. Sollte man da als Fußballverein vielleicht auch sich häufiger positionieren? Und zwar nicht nur, wenn irgendwas passiert ist. Nicht nur, wenn es mal Affenrufe oder irgendwelche homophoben oder rassistischen Vorfälle gab, sondern generell einfach sich als Verein sagen, hey, wir stehen für diese Werte. Und damit macht man ja auch für viele Fans, die eine andere Gesinnung haben, klar, naja gut, eigentlich bist du hier so nicht willkommen. Und damit antizitiert man das ja auch so ein bisschen.
Ja, ich glaube, dass es schon wichtig ist, dass sich immer wieder mal jemand dazu positioniert. Und was ich auch wichtig finde, ist, wie du gesagt hast, dass das nicht immer nur passiert, wenn was Schlimmes passiert ist. Weil dann ist klar, dass der Verein, dann steht ja der Verein auch in der Pflicht, was zu machen.
Genau, gucken wir alle hin.
Aber ich glaube, dass Dynamo das schon in gewisser Weise dann auch gemacht hat. Wir hatten ganz oft Kampagnen, Love Dynamo, Hate Racism und so Sachen. Ich glaube, dass da schon relativ viel gemacht wurde. Wie gesagt, schon alleine. Deswegen, weil wir wirklich zwischendurch dann fünf, sechs dunkelhäutige Spieler hatten. Und ja, da musst du natürlich auch gegensteuern. Aber das ist schon richtig. Aber vielleicht trauen sich da auch viele Spieler nicht dann in dem Maße was zu sagen. Weil du natürlich weißt, dass die Fans, wenn du da was Falsches sagst, und die hören ja alles, man glaubt nicht, die Fans gucken sich alles an. Und die hören jedes Wort, was du irgendwo vor Kamera oder vor Mikrofon sagst. Vielleicht gibt es da eine gewisse Angst von Spielern, die dann vielleicht denken, dann wird man nicht mehr gemocht oder so. Das kann ich mir schon vorstellen.
Ja, aber von manchen Leuten will ich doch vielleicht auch gar nicht gemocht werden.
Das ist wohl wahr. Aber wenn du mal als Spieler vor 30.000 ausgefiffen wirst, und jetzt nicht ausgefiffen, weil du jetzt einen Dynamo-Spieler umgetreten hast und die Fans mögen dich jetzt gerade mal nicht, sondern wirklich ausgefiffen, weil sie dich nicht mögen. Das ist schon eine harte Sache, muss man ehrlich sagen. Da muss man halt differenzieren. Und wie du sagst, für so etwas lohnt es sich eigentlich, auch so etwas mal auf sich zu nehmen. Deswegen würde man sich wünschen, dass man sich öfter mal besser positioniert, sowohl als Spieler als auch als auch der Verein. Ich glaube, dass da immer noch…
Ja, vor allem der Verein. Also die Spieler sind ja Teil des Vereins. Und natürlich begrüße ich das jetzt auch, wenn jeder einzelne Spieler vortritt und sagt, Rassismus finde ich scheiße, bleibt mir weg mit Humor Robin. Aber klar, dass auf den dann ganz anderer Druck lastet. Aber die Vereine könnten das doch viel offensiver machen. Und ich finde auch jenseits von irgendwelchen Kampagnen, es muss ja jetzt nicht jeder den FC St. Pauli kopieren, aber ein bisschen was davon abschauen könnte man sich zum Beispiel schon. Da ist ein fester Teil des Stadions immer unwiederbringlich ein riesengroßer Tribünteil, auf dem steht, wir sind gegen Rassismus, bleibt uns weg mit diesem Kram. Das hat hier keinen Platz. Und ich frage mich, warum sich der Fußball damit so schwer tut, denn gleichzeitig hat der Fußball so eine krasse Wirkmacht. Also über das Thema Fußball kannst du mit fast jedem Deutschen sprechen, oder jetzt gar nicht Deutschen, du kannst mit fast jedem Menschen darüber sprechen. Und dementsprechend wichtig ist er auch für die Gesellschaft. Und derzeit habe ich den Eindruck, man nimmt das so hin, dass man sich manchmal positionieren muss und ansonsten lässt man aber lieber das Finger vom Thema. Und das finde ich ist aber halt der zu einfache Weg, wenn du gerade auch feststellst, wir nehmen jetzt auf am 18. September, es werden auch viele Leute nach der Bundestagswahl erst hören. Aber wir sehen ja gerade, es gibt eine Extremisierung in der Gesellschaft. Es wird wieder Komot, Dinge zu sagen, für die du früher zu rechts, links und rechts – Na gut, ich bin nicht für Gewalt. Aber die du dir früher nicht getraut hättest, ist ein Problem. Und da muss man doch ein Gegengewicht setzen und das muss man doch jetzt setzen, nicht erst, wenn es wieder zu spät ist.
Das finde ich auch. Also da bin ich voll deiner Meinung, dass man da viel mehr präventiv arbeiten müsste und vielmehr schon alleine davor gegensteuern, gegen gewisse Bewegungen, wo du weißt, dass die passieren in deinem Umfeld. Und wie du sagst, bei Dynamo ist es natürlich jetzt im Speziellen so, dass die Fans auch relativ, also die haben eine gewisse Macht auf jeden Fall. Also das ist klar und das ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht nur da so, sondern auch in anderen Vereinen, wo es eine relativ starke Fangemeinschaft gibt. Aber damit musst du in gewisser Weise natürlich auch leben. Du willst die gute Stimmung, du willst, dass es immer ausverkauft ist. Da musst du natürlich damit auch ein bisschen leben, dass die natürlich ein gewisses Mitspracherecht wollen. Aber du musst es halt so hinbekommen, dass du dich trotzdem noch frei bewegen kannst oder dass du trotzdem freie Aktionen starten kannst, ohne dass du Angst haben musst, dass du dafür eine übergezogen kriegst. Also im übertragenen Sinne, nicht im wirklichen Sinne. Deswegen glaube ich, dass das ein Ansatz ist, den man durchaus aufgreifen müsste, dass man wirklich viel, viel mehr präventiv macht und nicht immer erst, wenn es passiert ist. Weil dann nimmt es einem natürlich auch in gewisser Weise keiner mehr ab. Weil es ist ja klar, dass der Verein dann was machen muss, wenn irgendwas passiert ist, dann wäre es ja fatal. Und dann kommen halt immer wieder dieselben Gedanken, die dann hochkommen. Und immer dieselben, ja, darf nicht passieren, wir verurteilen das aufs Schärfste.
Genau, wir distanzieren uns deutlich, ihr seid keine Fans.
Aber es ändert sich halt auch in gewisser Weise nicht. Es passieren immer wieder dieselben Sachen. Ich meine, klar, ich habe jetzt auch keinen, der hier ein Patentrezept vorlegt, wie es nicht mehr passiert.
Schade, dass wir den Rasenfunk mal pushen.
Das wäre eine schöne Sache, ja. Aber dafür bin ich auch nicht so tief im Thema drin, dass ich da was sagen kann. Ich weiß, dass das ein sehr, sehr schwieriges Thema ist, aber dass es natürlich trotzdem angegangen werden muss, auch wenn es schwierig ist, weil das wird kommen, wie du sagst. Die Welt und die Einsichten werden immer extremer und da musst du gegensteuern, wenn wir uns in den Fußball so erhalten wollen, wie wir ihn lieben. Wir haben ja vorhin schon bei der Privat mal geredet, das geht natürlich in eine Richtung, wo es nicht mehr der Fußball ist, den wir uns irgendwie vorstellen oder wo es sich entwickeln wird in die Richtung, die wir nicht mögen werden.
Definitiv, ja. Aber ich hätte zwar jetzt Lust, an das Gespräch von vorhin anzuknüpfen, aber dann glaube ich, können wir unseren Zeitplan nicht einhalten. Kommen wir mal zurück zum Sportlichen. Aufstieg in die zweite Bundesliga und jetzt befinden wir uns in der Saison 2011-2012. Und jetzt geht es mal so richtig ab, unter anderem ja im DFB-Pokal. Nimm mich mal so ein bisschen mit und die Hörerinnen und Hörer in diese Saison.
Ich nehme dich mit. Also das war natürlich da eine riesen Euphorie in Dresden, da musst du wissen, also eigentlich gibt es nur Schwarz und Weiß in Dresden. Also es gibt nur Dynamo, weil ihr seid oder ihr Spieler, es ist alles Katastrophe, was ihr macht oder wir werden auf Händen durch die Stadt getragen. Und man hat natürlich gemerkt, dass die Leute dann unheimlich gierig waren nach so einem professionellen Fußball wie in der zweiten Liga, nach der Mediengeschichte, die natürlich deutlich höher wurde nochmals in der dritten Liga. Du warst wieder bei Sky, du warst wieder auf der Landkarte im Fußball, das hat man natürlich gemerkt. Und dementsprechend waren die Erwartungen natürlich auch schon relativ hoch wieder. Wir waren kein normaler Aufsteiger, sondern wir waren schon so ein Aufsteiger, wo die Fans dachten, das ist zweite Liga, wir waren früher mal erste Liga, da gehören wir eigentlich auch hin. Und das packen wir schon irgendwie. Dann ging es relativ schleppend los, wir haben nicht so gut reingefunden, wie wir das wollten. Wir haben das erste Spiel in Cottbus verloren.
Eins zu zwei, genau.
Wir haben dann zuhause, glaube ich, unentschieden gegen Rostock gespielt, auch relativ brotlos bei den Spieler, also nicht so wirklich gut, und dann kam das DFB-Pokalspiel gegen Leverkusen, wo wir bei der Auslosung schon dachten, oh, schwer, sehr schwer. Die hatten Balak dazugeholt und hatten eine super Mannschaft, wirklich Schürrle, und wir dachten schon, okay, als Aufsteiger hast du eh nichts zu verlieren, guck mal mal. Dann gehen wir in dieses besagte Spiel rein, und die haben uns nach allen Regeln der Kunst auseinandergenommen. Also 1. Herze, wir waren nie einmal im Strafraum, glaube ich, und wir wussten nicht, wo vorne und hinten ist.
Nach zwölf Minuten schon 0 zu 2.
0 zu 2, und ein absoluter Albtraum eigentlich wirklich. Und ich kann mich noch erinnern, 2-0 stand auch in der Halbzeit, und wir sind in der Halbzeit rein. Ich habe Fiello angeguckt, weiß ich noch, und Fiello sagte Männer, hey, bitte, tut mir einen Gefallen, lass uns hinten gut stehen, lass uns nicht untergehen, weil die machen uns kaputt, wenn wir versuchen, offensiv zu spielen. Und wir dachten wirklich, hoffentlich ist das Spiel bald vorbei, die geben uns noch ein, zwei und dann ist es vorbei.
War das auch die Ansage von Ralf Loose, also dem Männern? Oder hat der eine andere Ansage gemacht?
Natürlich nicht, der hat natürlich gesagt, hey Männer, alles schön und gut, wir sind jetzt hier angekommen im DFB-Bokal, aber jetzt können wir mal den Körtel hinten rausnehmen, aus der Hose und vielleicht mal anfangen, wie Männer zu spielen. Und dann haben wir uns wieder ein bisschen hochgepusht. Die ersten fünf Minuten waren wirklich ernüchternd in der Kabine und wir haben gesagt, okay Männer, wir geben jetzt nochmal Volker, wir versuchen nochmal alles für die Fans und so. Erste Aktion.
Zack, 0 zu 3.
3-0, André Schürrle weiß ich noch, außen so nach innen gegangen, wie in Robben bei Nierbosel als rechts. Ne, der hat links gespielt und ist nach innen gezogen und hat dann so als Rechtsfuß den Ball in die lange Ecke geschlenzt. Okay, wir haben uns wieder alle angeguckt und dachten, Gott, du Gott, was soll das heute werden? Ah wirklich, lass uns zusammenreißen.
Ja, und dann kam der Dosenöffner, der mir das Gegenfeld sieht.
Was man nicht erklären kann, wir waren eigentlich mausetot, es war ein Freistoß aus dem Halbfeld. Michael Ballack hat mich gedeckt.
Oder auch nicht.
Er dachte wahrscheinlich auch nicht daran, in seinen kühnsten Träumen, dass das hier noch… Man muss dazu sagen, der wurde 3-0 für die. Rolf ist ausgewechselt, Ballack rein.
Denkst du dir auch, ja geil.
Hoffentlich macht er jetzt hier nicht noch den großen Zampano und nimmt uns komplett auseinander. Aber es war halt im Gegenteil der Fall. Cielo bringt den Ball, ich mache das Kopfball-Tor und dann war die Stimmung im Stadion. Das war immer noch nicht so, dass du dachtest, jetzt machen wir die hier, jetzt geht es los. Also auch nicht. Die Leute haben sich gefreut, aber es war immer noch so ein bisschen eine verhaltende Stimmung. Dann aber hast du richtig gemerkt, wie das Spiel gekippt ist. Es war supergeil zu merken, dass auch solche Spieler wie die von Leverkusen, die so ein Selbstvertrauen hatten in der ersten Halbzeit und es gar nicht am Ball kommen lassen haben, dass die dann auch angefangen haben zu überlegen, wenn wir jetzt noch eins kriegen, dann brennt die Hütte hier aber. Und so war es dann auch. Nochmal Freistoß, glaube ich. Kori macht das Tor und dann ist das Ding explodiert. Dann hast du gedacht, da fliegt gleich die Schüssel ab oben. Das war unfassbare Stimmung, so laut. Und du hast richtig gemerkt, wir machen noch das dritte. Da war ich mir relativ sicher, als wir das zweite gemacht haben, dass wir auch noch das dritte machen. Und dann machen wir das auch wieder, Kori, glaube ich. Der hat dann schon die Aufstiegs-Tore gemacht, der war dann ein absoluter Dynamo-Hero. Das war wirklich die Krönung seines Schaffens, dass er da nochmal einen Doppelpack gemacht hat. Dann ging es in die Verlängerung, 3-3, und wir waren schon ein bisschen selbstbewusster. Wir haben uns schon gedacht, Männer, hier geht was. Wir versuchen jetzt zu gucken, ob wir eventuell ein Tor machen, oder wir machen es halt im Elberschießen nachher. Und gut, dann kam der Moment von Alex Schnetzler. Wir hatten dann noch ein paar wüste Szenen zu überstehen, da waren auch ein paar Glücksmomente dabei, wo Schürrle dann nochmal verzogen hat. Aber das Glück brauchst du eben dann auch in so einem Spiel. Und dann ging Alex Schnetzler von der Mittellinie allein aufs Tor zu. Und ich war dann schon raus, ich hatte irgendwie einen Krampf gekriegt in der 103. oder 105. oder so. Und der kam für mich rein, der Alex. Ich weiß noch, Ecke für die, glaube ich, konnte er. Und er läuft von der Mittellinie allein zu. Und ich saß auf der Bank und gefühlt hat er eine Minute gebraucht, um zum Tor zu kommen. Aber nicht weil er so langsam war, sondern weil das in meinem Kopf, das ging wie so eine Zeitlupe ab. Der ist gelaufen, der ist gelaufen und ich sehe ihn auf seinem linken Fuß. Und ich wusste, mit links ist es okay, aber ich wusste nicht, wer ihn reinmachen wollte mit links. Und dann chippte er den da drüber über, ich weiß nicht, wer der am Tor war. Heldell. Heldell war am Tor, genau. In einer Manier, wie es eigentlich nur Weltklasse-Stürmer machen mit dem schwachen Fuß. Und vier-drei für uns und Spiel aus. Wahnsinn, wirklich. Also sowas hatte ich noch nie erlebt und ich dachte auch nicht, dass es möglich ist, eine Bundesligistin nach einem 0-3 noch zu schlagen. Und Ausnahmestimmung im Stadion wirklich, also sowas habe ich fast nie wieder erlebt. Ein- zweimal danach vielleicht noch, da kommen wir vielleicht noch mal nachher drauf. Aber was da für eine Stimmung war, da habe ich dann das erste Mal wirklich gesehen, dass es unfassbar was hier möglich ist in der Stadt mit den Fans zusammen. Und wenn du nur ein bisschen Druck machst, dann war das wirklich ein absoluter Hexenkessel. Und dann haben wir die rausgehauen. Es war ein unglaublich euphorischer Tag. Wir hatten dann auch Mannschaftsabend, wir haben da alles abgerissen in Dresden an dem Abend. Wir haben das in vollen Zügen genossen und hatten dann auch so ein bisschen den Liga-Alltag weggewischt, weil das wirklich noch nicht so gut war und es sollte dann auch weiter nicht so gut bleiben. Und das war wirklich ganz cool. Und dann gab es so eine Phase, dann waren wir wieder nicht so gut, die nächsten zwei Spiele nicht so gut. Und dann war auch bei mir ein bisschen der Knut, ich hatte dann so eine Rückengeschichte, wo ich immer wieder Krämpfe hatte und keiner so richtig wusste, was da los war. Und es hat sich dann herausgestellt, dass das so eine Lendenwirbel-Geschichte war, die so einen Nerv zugedrückt hat und der dann immer wieder zu Krämpfen geführt hat, obwohl ich quasi, das war immer so 50. oder 60. und die Leute da haben mich angeguckt und gesagt, ist das dein Ernst, was für Krämpfe sollst du haben? Und ich sage selber, keine Ahnung, was das ist, ich weiß es nicht, ich bin fit, aber… Ja, und dann kam es, dass der Trainer mich rausgenommen hat und einen neuen Spieler geholt hat, dann für links vor der Ende der Transferperiode, der hat dann gespielt, im ersten Spiel direkt zwei Tore gemacht, Muhammed Zubasic, hieß der so in Bosnia. Und dann dachte ich wieder, Mann, zweite Liga, das soll irgendwie nicht sein, das funktioniert gerade nicht. Und dann habe ich wirklich, ich glaube, sieben, acht, zehn Spiele vielleicht auf der Bank gesessen, kam wenig rein, selten. Und dann kam, glaube ich, da das Spiel, war die zweite Runde Hannover DFB-Bukal oder Dortmund?
Nee, das war gegen Dortmund.
Das war dann Dortmund, ne? Ja, das war dann natürlich auch so ein schwarzer Tag im Dynamo-Leben, was da passiert ist. Das war eigentlich für uns natürlich überragend. Ich meine, gegen Dortmund, in Dortmund auch noch, das war natürlich diese doofe DFB-Bokal-Regel, dass die dann zuerst gezogen wurden und wir dann da spielen mussten, quasi. Aber war natürlich ein Erlebnis, wir haben natürlich auch wieder 20.000 mitgenommen oder 15.000, das ist unfassbar, was da dann für Stimmung war, weil man hat richtig gemerkt, die BVB-Fans, als wir das Stadion angeschaut haben, quasi vor dem Spiel, also wir sind angekommen, sind mal auf dem Rasen gegangen kurz, da waren dann schon gefühlte 15.000 da, und dann haben die mal kurz angestimmt, dann hat man auch an den BVB-Fans gemerkt, oh, das ist Konkurrenz für uns, das haben die dann schon gemerkt. Und dementsprechend war es dann auch ein heißes Spiel, die Dortmund-Fans haben natürlich auch alles gegeben dann nachher, also die haben dann gemerkt, man, heute müssen wir alles geben, hier stimmungstechnisch, dass wir hier in der Oberhand bleiben. Und dann war es eigentlich auch ein relativ gutes Spiel von uns, glaube ich, zwei Null nur verloren, das war Dortmunds absolute Blütezeit. Also das war, die hatten alles, was Rang und Namen hatte, Lewandowski, Götze, Kagawa.
Großkreuz in der WM-Form, also vor der WM-Hummel hinten drin, ja, war halt die meiste Saison.
Zwei Null verloren und dann halt dieses Spiel Unterbrechung zwischendurch dann und da...
Warst du da noch auf dem Platz gestanden, als das Spiel mitgebracht wurde?
Ja, ich bin reingekommen zur Halbzeit, glaube ich.
Für den Helden Alex Schnetzler?
Genau, das war so reiflose Move, so typisch. Der hat dann gesagt, Alex Schnetzler hat im ganzen Jahr fast kein Spiel gemacht. Der war immer der gute Stimmungsmann, der draußen gesessen hat. Da hat er gesagt, du hast uns in die Runde gebracht, also spielst du auch in Dortmund. Eigentlich hätte ich sauer sein müssen, aber ich fand es trotzdem cool, dass er es gemacht hat. Und der Schnetzler hat es auch verdient gehabt, deswegen war es völlig in Ordnung. Er hat dann auch zu mir gesagt, du kommst auf jeden Fall. Ich bin dann in die Halbzeit gekommen und war natürlich ein geiles Erlebnis. Ich war fast ausverkauft, ich glaube 72.000 oder so.
Und wie nimmt man so eine Spielunterbrechung wahr? Du bist ja sowieso in so einem sportlichen Tunnel. Dann wirst du aus dem Tunnel krassestmöglich rausgerissen. Und dann, wie sind dann auch die Ansagen? Es geht ja nie eine Mannschaft dann geschlossen in die Kurve und sagt, jetzt lass den Scheiß sein, wir wollen hier Fußball spielen, sondern wenn, dann geht mal ein Einzender nach vorne. Ist es auch so bewusst, dass die Funktionäre versuchen, einen im sportlichen Fokus zu halten, dass man sich nicht ablenken lässt? Oder wie ist sowas?
Na ja, klar. Also ich meine, im Normalfall geht immer der Kapitän hin oder der Trainer oder irgendein Spieler, der jetzt Dresdner ist oder so, oder sich mit denen komplett identifizieren oder die sich auch mit denen. Weil es ist natürlich wichtig, wenn da irgendeiner hingeht, dann interessiert die das ja gar nicht. Also da muss schon jemand hingehen, vor dem die auch ein bisschen Respekt haben quasi. Und wo die dann auch sagen, wenn der jetzt was sagt, dann hören zumindest mal kurz alle zu. Und ich weiß gar nicht, was dann… das war ja dann alles so unübersichtlich. Ich wusste trotzdem nicht so richtig, was los war. Ich habe dann mit Kähl, weiß ich noch, da gestanden und der hat nur gefragt, was ist los mit euren Leuten? Ich konnte selbst nicht so richtig sagen, ich bin da gerade reingekommen, war froh, dass ich gut im Spiel war und habe dann da auch so ein bisschen den Überblick verloren. Also ich konnte mir da keinen Reim drauf machen, was da jetzt genau passiert ist. Ich habe natürlich gesehen, dass da Leute Angst hatten und dass da irgendwas vor sich ging, aber was genau habe ich dann auch nicht wahrgenommen, weil dann ging es auch irgendwie relativ schnell wieder weiter nach ein paar Minuten. Und dann war es halt immer noch ein DFB-Bukalspiel, wo du dachtest, wenn wir hier nochmal ein Tor machen, dann steht es 1-2. Wir wussten selbst aus der Runde davor, dass alles möglich war und haben das dann nicht so richtig wahrgenommen und sind dann beim 2-0 geblieben. Im Nachhinein hat man natürlich mitgekriegt, was da los war. Das ist natürlich dann eine blöde Situation. Du bist ja auch machtlos, was willst du machen auf dem Platz? Die Fans hören natürlich dann auch nur bedingt, wenn ein Spieler kommt und sagt, bleib mal ruhig, dann hilft das natürlich vielleicht, zehn Leute zu beruhigen. Aber das Gros der Leute ist natürlich in ihrem Tunnel da auch gerade und kriegen da nicht so richtig was mit. Und deswegen fühlst du dich da auch so gewisserweise ein bisschen machtlos.
Also es gab eben mehrmals Pyrotechnik, es wurden Gegenstände aufs Spielfeld geworfen und nach dem Spiel ging es dann richtig los, hingen auch bestimmt damit zusammen. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht mehr ganz sicher, aber ich glaube, die Polizei hat auch versucht, Leute, die während des Spiels was gemacht haben, aus dem Block rauszukriegen. Und dann wurde es noch schlimmer.
Ich meine, Pyrotechnik, daran musst du dich als Dresden-Spieler auch gewöhn. Hattest du da vorher eine Meinung zu?
Oder war das egal?
Nein, also eine Meinung, ich meine, ich finde das eine ganz schwierige Diskussion. Ich kann verstehen, dass die sagen, weil die damit immer, weil die da halt, die hantieren damit immer rum und sagen, wenn wir das machen, dann passiert da schon nichts. Wir wissen schon, wie das funktioniert irgendwie. Aber das ist eben halt das große Unbekannte. Ich finde, das kannst du halt nicht durchgehen lassen als Aussage quasi. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das hier funktionieren könnte in so einem abgesperrten Bereich. Ich glaube, dass da schöne Sachen entstehen könnten irgendwie, wenn das in irgendeiner Bahn abläuft, wo da gewisse Regelungen sind und wo da so Banden sind, in die sie sich aufhalten können. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das hier kommen wird. Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht. Es ist schwer für mich zu sagen. Wie gesagt, die Fans haben ja auch manchmal mitten in der Stadt zu irgendeinem Jubiläum mit Bengalos so eine geile Art Choreo gemacht. Das ist natürlich Wahnsinn, super. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das in so einem engen Stadion möglich ist, das gefahrenfrei durchzuführen. Ich habe da meine Bedenken, ehrlich gesagt.
Wer schon mal mit jemandem gesprochen hat, der mit Pyrotechnik negativ in Berührung kam, ich kenne da jemanden, der hat mir zu mir gesagt, er kann bis heute den Geruch von angebrannten Fleisch nicht riechen. Das fand ich so einen krassen Satz, da muss ich mich immer dran erinnern.
Ja, das glaube ich. Ich glaube auch, dass es eigentlich nicht durchsetzbar ist, so schlecht sich als einige fühlen werden. Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das eine Zukunft hat. Aber wie gesagt, da muss ich mich als Dynamo-Spieler daran gewöhnen, dass das nur wieder mal passiert. Das war jetzt nichts Neues, dass ich da Pyro-Technik gesehen habe.
Wahnsinn, Wahnsinns-Saison. Und es ging dann in die Relegation?
In dem Jahr nicht. In dem Jahr haben wir es relativ entspannt geschafft. Da habe ich dann auch im Winter wieder gespielt. Und da kommen wir jetzt auch wieder zur Elfmetersituation zurück. Da habe ich dann im Spiel gegen FSV Frankfurt – da mache ich meinen einzigen Doppelpack in meiner Karriere, wo ich als Linksverteidiger einen Head-Track machen könnte. Da ärgere ich mich noch heute darüber. Da spielen wir gegen FSV Frankfurt. Ich mache direkt das 1-0, dann Elfmeter, 2-0, beide Tore gemacht. Und dann machen die es 2-1 irgendwann und zum Schluss kriegen wir wieder ein Elfmeter. Und ja, gut, das war für mich klar, dass ich den rein mache. Ich wusste auch, Patrick Lant war im Tor. Ich war mir relativ sicher, dass er in die andere Ecke springt, wo ich den ersten hingeschossen habe, was er auch gemacht hat. Aber ich habe ihm in die andere Ecke etwas zu gut gezielt und springt dann in den Pfosten und springt wieder raus. Und das war dann so das erste Mal, wo ich nachgedacht habe nach Elfmetern. Da kam dann auch so eine Sache. Dann habe ich noch mal einen verschossen danach gegen Cottbus, mein Heimatverein, wo wir 1-0 geführt haben, auch in der 88. Das war dann noch mal später in der Saison, in der Rückrunde. Da habe ich dann noch mal verschossen und habe gerechnet, naja, zwei von vier ist nicht so glorreich. Und dann habe ich beschlossen, meine Elfmeter-Karriere an den Nagel zu hängen und gesagt, das können andere bestimmt besser. Und so kam das dann natürlich auch im späteren Verlauf nachher, wenn wir nochmal darauf zu sprechen kommen, dass ich da eben nicht mehr aufgetaucht bin auf der Schützenliste von Elfmetern.
Jetzt verstehe ich das besser. Genau, also dieses Spiel mit den zwei Treffern gegen Frankfurt war tatsächlich dann schon in der nächsten Saison, als es dann wieder in die Relegation ging. Aber die Saison, über die wir gerade gesprochen haben, mit dem Dortmundspiel mit dem Leverkusenspiel, da war im Platz 8 riesige Überraschung, kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, wie gut Dresden da abgeschnitten hat, wirklich tolle Runde gespielt.
Ich glaube, ich habe dann diese zehn Spiele lang nicht gespielt gehabt und habe dann kurz vorm Winter wieder gespielt und habe dann auch durchgespielt bis zum Schluss, war dann auch wieder stabil und alles war wieder in Ordnung. Und dann kam das Jahr danach, dann wurde Ralf Lohse relativ schnell entlassen, glaube ich noch ein paar Spiele schon. Und dann kam Peter Packholt. Das war das, was ich später gemeint habe, da dachte ich eigentlich, das war wieder komplett alte Schule wie früher, gar nicht geredet einfach. Da ist man manchmal an dem Morgens vorbei gelaufen, Morgentrainer und einfach durchgelaufen, ohne was zu sagen. Ein ganz eigener Typ wirklich, aber in dem Moment genau der Richtige auch für uns, weil er so ein Disziplinfanatiker war. Wir hatten diese vielen Ausländer in der Mannschaft und diese Franzosengemeinschaft. Er war genau der Richtige, der hatte auf keinen irgendwas gegeben, dem war alles egal, egal wer das war. Er hat uns über die blanke Diktatur wieder Leben eingehaucht. Das funktioniert natürlich dann auch eine Weile. Für mich stirbt dieses Diktatur sein oder Diktator als Trainer, die Alleinherrschaft und immer alles, das stirbt irgendwann aus. Ich glaube, das ist eine Art von Trainern. Man kann es ja auch wieder ändern, das ist kein Problem. Das funktioniert nur über einen gewissen Zeitraum. Irgendwann nutzt sich das ab. Das schaffst du dann nicht zu halten, dieses Niveau über diese Jahre. Du kriegst die Mannschaft auch nicht mehr auf deine Seite irgendwann.
Ich glaube, dass die Rohade, die du gerade siehst, wird gerade zu einer Trainergeneration ausgewächst. Das hat nicht nur damit zu tun, dass die neuen Trainer mutmaßlich alle ganz toll sind, sondern auch damit, dass das, was viele etablierte Trainer anbieten, heute einfach so nicht mehr gefragt ist, weil sich wahrscheinlich auch der Typ an Spielern geändert hat. Der sich auch nicht mehr alles bieten lässt und der vielleicht aber auch viel kritischer hinterfragt. Wenn er dann sagt, warum haben wir denn jetzt die Übung hier gemacht, ist es jetzt darum, wie wir uns in Überzeitsituationen verhalten und wie wir den Ball schnell wieder verschieben. Und man hat da keine Antwort darauf, dann sinkt der Respekt des Trainers wahrscheinlich.
Genau, und wenn du halt nur über blanke Übungen die Spieler nicht kaputt machen willst, aber denen zeigen willst, dass du die absolute Oberhand hast, und das war wirklich ein Hates. Also im Nachhinein – wir haben uns jetzt ein paar Mal gesehen – bin ich ihm auch in gewisser Weise wieder ein bisschen dankbar, weil er wirklich – ich dachte, dass ich keinen guten Stand habe, aber im Nachhinein habe ich gehört, dass er mich eigentlich wirklich auch vor Oberen oft verteidigt hat.
Aber das aber auch schon für einen Satz.
Ja, ich dachte wirklich, dass ich bei ihm nicht so ein – weil er hat mich immer, er hat mich brutal kritisiert, er hat mich wirklich angeschrien auf den Platz manchmal, wo ich wirklich in seiner unnachahmlichen österreichischen Art wirklich zusammengestaucht, so klein war ich mit Hut. Ich meine, du hast 32 Spiele gemacht, das ist ja – ich staune nicht, dass du gedacht hast – ich habe dir gesagt, dass ich dann gelernt habe, auch wenn ich vermeintlich nicht dieses super Vertrauen von ihm gespürt habe, aber dann trotzdem meine Leistung zu bringen. Und das war dann, glaube ich, im Endeffekt auch mein bestes Zweitliga-Jahr, was ich je gespielt habe dann in dem Jahr mit Packholt. Ich hatte relativ zeitig auch ein paar Tore und ein paar Assists und habe dann auch wirklich richtig gut gespielt. Und es war leider aber trotzdem das Jahr, wo wir als Mannschaft nicht so den Erfolg hatten. Und wir waren dann bis zum Schluss unten drin und mussten dann Relegation spielen und zum Glück wieder gegen Osnabrück.
Wieder beim ersten Spiel nicht im Kader?
Wieder fünfte Gelbe im letzten Spiel gegen Regensburg, weiß ich noch, zu Hause. Und wir haben dann die Relegation da wieder gesperrt und mein Konkurrent immer noch derselbe, der mich im Jahr davor dann mal kurz abgelöst hatte, hat dann in Osnabrück gespielt. Und wir haben es eigentlich da ganz ordentlich gemacht. Wir haben, glaube ich, trotzdem 1-0 verloren und die haben noch einen Elfer verschossen. Also wir hätten eigentlich fast 2-0 verlieren müssen, aber wir haben nur 1-0 verloren, zum Glück. Und dann hat der Trainer auch zu mir gesagt, der hat das jetzt super gemacht, ich lasse den jetzt drin, weil das halt gut funktioniert. Und da war ich auch damit okay, also mir ging es da wirklich nur darum, die Klasse zu sichern. Das war dann 2012, 2013 reden wir, oder? Das war dann auch das Jahr, wo ich meine Frau geheiratet habe und ich wusste im Sommer ist meine Hochzeit, ich will auf gar keinen Fall absteigen vor meiner Hochzeit. Und wir haben Osnabrück wirklich zu Hause komplett zerstört. Das war dann so ein Spiel, das gehörte mindestens 50 Prozent den Fans, weil die hatten so ein Ding in der Hose hinten. Das war von Anfang an klar, dass wir das Spiel gewinnen. Es war dann 2-0. Jello hat ein sensationelles Tor gemacht, weiß ich noch, genau im Winkel. Wali hat dann nachher noch das 2-0 gemacht, aber es war relativ ungefährdet. Auch wenn es natürlich irgendwie spannend war bis zum Schluss. Aber wir haben die da wirklich vom Tor weggehalten. Ich kam dann noch rein kurz vor Schluss und habe dann noch mit das Ergebnis gesichert. Das war wirklich vollkommen okay an dem Tag für mich. Ich war ultra froh, dass wir das irgendwie geschafft haben. Dann war das Jahr vorbei, ich habe geheiratet.
Ganz kurz noch, findest du als jemand, der davon positiv betroffen war, aber findest du relegationgerecht? Findest du es gut, dass es das gibt nach 34 Spieltagen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht. Obwohl ich davon jetzt profitiert habe. Ich hätte ja quasi zwei Mal wäre ich direkt aufgestiegen und einmal wäre ich mal abgestiegen im Normalfall mit Dynamo. Da ist es natürlich gut, aber ich finde schon, dass wenn du unter die ersten drei kommst und drei steigen auf, dann solltest du auch aufsteigen dürfen im Endeffekt. Der 16. Wirt hat es dann wahrscheinlich auch nicht verdient drin zu bleiben, meiner Meinung nach. Ich halte davon nichts, vor allen Dingen, weil der Druck so immens hoch ist in den Spielen. Das ist unfassbar, vor allen Dingen für die Mannschaft, die dann absteigt. Für die aufsteigende Mannschaft ist natürlich ein anderer Druck, sagen wir mal so. Es ist wie so, ab letztes Mal mit jemandem geredet, es ist ein komplett anderer Druck, aufsteigen zu wollen oder zu müssen und nicht absteigen zu sollen. Also das ist schon, das ist was ganz anderes, das kann man nicht beschreiben, weil diese eine Angst lähmt dich quasi manchmal, diese Abstiegsangst. Und dieses Aufstiegsdruck ist eher, den kann man eher positiv um Münzen für mich. Also ich zumindest kann das. Es wird sicherlich auch Leute geben, die sagen, das finde ich jetzt gar nicht so. Aber ich kann das in ein positives Umfeld, weil du kannst ja quasi nur gewinnen. Klar, du steigst auf und im schlechtesten Fall schaffst du es nicht und versuchst es am nächsten Jahr nochmal. Aber Absteigen, das ist dann so etwas Endgültiges. Dann werden wieder Leute entlassen und dieses ganze Thema schwebt dann sowieso um dich herum. Und alle sagen, ihr könnt ja froh sein, ihr kriegt ja eh wieder irgendwo einen Job, aber die Leute, die da entlassen werden und die Konsequenzen, die das mit sich zieht, das ist dann natürlich was, was du dir nicht gerne anheften willst, was nicht gerne in deiner Vita drinstehen soll, dass du mal abgestiegen bist. Und deswegen lehnt dich das brutal manchmal wirklich. Also das ist nicht zu erklären manchmal.
Kann man Abstiegskampf aus dem Alltag raushalten? Ich meine, wenn du schon sagst, du wolltest wenige Wochen vor deiner Hochzeit nicht absteigen, dann zeigt das ja schon, wie dominant dieses Thema ist. Wie ist das? Du hast ja mehrmals bei Vereinen Spielzeiten gespielt, wo irgendwie der Wurm drin war und wo man einfach so hinten drin hängt und man kommt da nicht raus, egal was man macht. Man kommt da nicht raus. Andererseits kann man sich ja davon auch nicht ein komplettes Jahr lang sein Leben versauern lassen, aber wie ist das?
Also das ist schon schwer. Vor allen Dingen jetzt in dem Jahr, im Abstiegsjahr mit Dynamo und jetzt im letzten Jahr mit Bielefeld, das ist brutal, das zerrt an deinen Nerven. Du wirst da gefühlt, sind das zwei Saisons, die du da durchstehen musst. Weil du nimmst das natürlich überall mit hin. Vor allen Dingen in Städten wie Dresden und Bielefeld, wo Fußball absolut Nummer eins ist. Du bist natürlich auch tagtäglich konfrontiert damit. Das geht gar nicht anders. Du kannst dich da nicht frei machen davon. Du bist immer mit den Leuten unterwegs und irgendeiner sieht dich immer und dann wirst du immer darauf angesprochen. Es ist allgegenwärtig einfach. Du kannst dich da nicht entziehen. Du kannst mal für ein Wochenende wegfahren, wenn mal frei ist oder so. Aber du kannst dich da aus der Sache nicht entziehen. Das ist einfach ein stetiges Ding, was in deinem Kopf drin ist. Also Abstiegskampf ist brutal. Ich muss sagen, ich habe in meinem Leben, glaube ich, öfter gegen den Abstieg gespielt als um den Aufstieg. Und deswegen, glaube ich, kann ich das mit relativer Gewissheit sagen, dass das wirklich an deinen Nerven zehrt ohne Ende.
Kriegt man dann eine Routine irgendwann oder ist es jedes Mal gleich?
Nee, ich glaube mittlerweile habe ich schon ein ganz gutes Gefühl dafür, ob du das schaffen kannst als Mannschaft oder nicht. Und ob du es dann schaffst, ist noch mal eine andere Sache, aber ob es überhaupt möglich ist. Manchmal ist es wirklich aufgrund der Zusammenstellung der Mannschaft oder aufgrund der Charaktereigenschaften der Spieler manchmal bis zu dazu verdammt, das nicht zu schaffen, weil du einfach keine Truppe bist irgendwie. Aber im Abstiegsjahr dann sozusagen mit Dresden, da war es halt wirklich, wir waren gute Einzelspieler, alle Spieler haben danach auch gute Mannschaften bekommen. Das ist auch so ein Phänomen, was es im Fußball gibt, vor allen Dingen hier in der zweiten Liga manchmal. Wenn Mannschaften absteigen, da gehen die Spieler dann zu Vereinen, Wahnsinn, und die blühen dann wieder auf. Und so war es auch bei uns damals. Also in dem Jahr, dann wurde Peter Pakult relativ schnell entlassen, wenn wir jetzt mal darauf zu sprechen kommen. Da war dann auch, wie gesagt, das hat er sich dann schon abgenutzt. Und auch wenn jetzt der Eindruck entsteht, dass Peter Pakult kein guter Trainer ist, möchte ich ein bisschen revidieren, dass er halt seine Art hat, die er mitbekommen hat. Und die funktioniert auch in gewisser Art und Weise. Aber es ist halt eine Art, die sich schneller abnutzt als andere Arten, weil es halt wie gesagt immer nur auf Druck und immer nur auf, wenn heute nicht, dann bist du draußen. Dann hast du das Gefühl, dass du wenig vertrauen, sondern immer viel Druck sozusagen. Und jetzt wird der meinte oder der meine Zuschauer sagen, ja Druck gehört dazu, ja, gehört dazu. Aber du kannst natürlich trotzdem besser spielen, wenn du Vertrauen spürst, als wenn du immer nur dieses Männchen im Ohr hast, was dir sagt, wenn du heute nicht gut spürst, dann bist du draußen das nächste Mal.
Vor allem ist Druck ja auch nicht steigerbar. Also wie viele Spiele deines Lebens sollst du machen? 38 pro Saison, das geht ja auch nicht.
Deswegen wurde dann relativ schnell entlassen, dann kam Olaf Jansen. Und wir waren wie gesagt eine Truppe voller ordentlicher bis guter Einzelspieler. Aber wir haben es halt nicht geschafft, uns zusammen zu rauf. Wir gab es dann diesen Franzosen-Blog von sechs Franzosen, wo dann natürlich wenig Sprachkenntnisse da waren. Und es ist natürlich auch klar, wenn du sechs auf einen Haufen steckst, dass die dann immer zusammenhängen. Also das kannst du dir denen jetzt auch nicht so richtig vorwerfen, weil das war halt dann so eine Sache, das wirst du wahrscheinlich auch machen, wenn du im Ausland bist und du hast da zwei Landsleute von dir in deiner Gemeinschaft. Du seist jetzt nicht mal auf Fußball bezogen, sondern auch aufs normale Leben. Da arbeiten zwei Deutsche in deiner Firma, dann wirst du wahrscheinlich mit denen auch erstmal ein bisschen mehr machen als mit den anderen. Vielleicht entwickelt es sich, einige haben es dann besser gemacht, einige nicht. Und somit waren wir dann ein ziemlich auseinandergewirbelter Haufen und die Fans haben das auch gemerkt. Es war das Jahr über keine gute Stimmung und das meine ich damit auch. Die Fans haben dann auch so, das war dann auch psychischer Druck so ein bisschen. Also wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht mit Absicht, aber die haben dann halt eine Erwartungshaltung und wir konnten die nicht erfüllen und die konnten das nicht verstehen. Und die konnten nicht verstehen, wie wir manchmal aufgetreten sind. So hat sich das dann, das war dann keine gute Beziehung wirklich. Da fühlt sich dann halt jeder immer schlecht behandelt. Irgendwie wir denken, die könnten noch ein bisschen mehr Geduld haben. Die denken, die müssten sich erstmal in den Arsch aufreißen, bevor sie von uns irgendwas bekommen. Und so war das dann so eine Stimmung, die nicht dazu beigetragen hat, dass beide irgendwie ihre Bestleistungen bringen konnten. Und folgerichtig war es dann natürlich auch ein absolutes Herzschlagfinale dieses Spiel zu Hause gegen Bielefeld.
Am 34. Spieltag, ihr als 16. Bielefeld als 17.
Wir hatten leider, dass Bielefeld so ein bisschen die bessere Ausgangsposition hatte, weil die mussten, die mussten unbedingt und wir konnten. Für uns hätte auch ein Unentschieden gereicht, um in der Relegation zu bleiben oder um den Relegationsplatz sicher zu haben. Und das war für uns so ein bisschen blöd für uns, weil die wussten, die konnten nur eine Richtung nach vorne. Und wir dachten, Mann, Unentschieden, das hast du halt immer ein bisschen im Hinterkopf, wenn du sagst, jetzt steht 0-0, das reicht uns ja jetzt. Das würde uns erreichen in dem Moment. Und dann kriegen die noch eine rote Karte, das weiß ich noch, nach 30 Minuten oder 25 Minuten. Und dann denkst du natürlich, ja, okay, was soll jetzt schiefgehen noch? Das schaffen wir. Und dann kriegen wir das 1-0 in Unterzahl. Klosi, Fabian Klos machts Tor. Und die Fans haben natürlich schon vor dem Spiel, muss ich noch dazu sagen, da muss ich nochmal drauf eingehen, vom Hotel zum Stadion gefahren. Und die Fans haben uns sozusagen wie so eine Spalier gestanden, den letzten Kilometer gefühlt. Und das war so eine – ich wusste nicht, was ich fühlen sollte. Das war einerseits wahnsinnig emotional so, weil die uns klarmachen wollten, es geht um alles und es geht um den kompletten Verein. Wenn wir absteigen, dann wer weiß, ob wir wieder hochkommen. Und das war wie so eine Art – ich hatte nicht das Gefühl, dass sie an uns geglaubt haben. Und wir hatten auch selbst nicht das Gefühl, dass wir an uns glauben irgendwie. Und das war dann so eine gewisse Zwischen – auch so ein bisschen Angst, weil da haben die dann auch so Böller gegen den Bus geworfen und so. Ich weiß noch, das war dann so eine Stimmung. Ich wusste nicht so richtig, ob ich davon motiviert sein sollte oder auch nicht. Ob ich so ein bisschen – Ob es Einschüchterung ist. Ob es Einschüchterung ist, genau, richtige Wort habe ich. Und ja, wie gesagt, wahnsinnig. Ich habe da noch ein Video im Kopf, was einer von unseren Spielern gemacht hat. Das war der Busfahrrad, nichts mehr gesehen, alles voller gelber Rauch. Und einerseits, wie gesagt, Wahnsinn. Und andererseits Einschüchtern. Und so war dann das Spiel auch wirklich. Wir kriegen dann nach der Halbzeit, weil das ja blöd war, 11 gegen 10 zu spielen, hat sich einer von uns gedacht, dann haue ich auch mal einen um, dann sind wir wieder 10 gegen 10. Dann glaube ich gleich nach der Halbzeit, dann machen die es 2-0. Und dann ging es natürlich ab, dann kam da ein Böller aufs Spielfeld geflogen und fünf Meter neben mir ist der explodiert, das war halt unwirklich irgendwie.
Das war ja sehr gefährlich halt auch.
Super gefährlich und super laut. Du hast es halt gar nicht erwartet in dem Moment. Du wusstest, die Fans sind sauer, aber ich habe jetzt nicht erwartet, dass da einer so ein Ding auf so eine halbe Handgranate aufs Spielfeld schmeißt, die wirklich zusammengezuckt und Schiri sofort rein. So geht es nicht, so können wir nicht zu Ende spielen. Rein 2-0 für die, die Fans. Also wirklich so ein Gesicht. Ich habe die noch im Kopf heute, wo ich da reingeguckt habe. Wahnsinn, wie sauer die waren, wie enttäuscht die waren von uns. Man hat wirklich gesehen, dass die am Boden zerstört waren und einfach nur sauer, einfach angepisst richtig. Und dann weiß ich noch, Dixie Dörner hat gesagt, nein, wir bleiben draußen. Wir bleiben draußen, geht nicht rein, Biele fällt sofort rein. Und wir haben dann draußen gestanden und dann sind gleich wir hingegangen. Aber wir wurden da so wüstbeleidigt. Da war keine Chance für Beschwichtigung oder irgendwie. Wir sind dahingegangen, die haben sofort gesagt, verpisst euch und wir wollen euch nicht sehen. Haut ab. Also das war wirklich so ein, wie gesagt, da hat man gemerkt, wie groß die Höhe ist.
Müsste man da nicht einfach auch mal gehen? Müsste man da nicht vielleicht auch als Mannschaft sagen, okay, gut, dann gehen wir halt. Und wir sind direkt abgestiegen und wir probieren es nicht, wenigstens auch noch. Ich mein, klar, es ist natürlich ein – jetzt weiß ich gerade nicht mehr, wie der Titel heißt – aber Massenverhalten und Intelligenz der Masse. Und da potenziert sich jede Emotion, im Guten wie im Schlechten. Aber trotzdem ist natürlich die Frage, können wir jetzt natürlich an einem Tisch ein paar Jahre später sehr gut stellen, aber was soll einem aufs Spielfeld geworfene Böller helfen in der Situation? Also ja, derjenige, der ihn geworfen hat, oder diejenige, der hat damit gesagt, ich bin scheiß wütend. Aber was verspricht man sich davon? Und ich finde das schon interessant, dass es Fanszenen gibt, wo sowas immer wieder vorkommt, wo Frust sich sehr, sehr schnell ins Negative potenziert. Und dass es aber auch Fanszenen gibt, die das schaffen, selbst in diesen Momenten, wo es am schwierigsten ist. Also im Erfolg hinter der Mannschaft zu stehen, mega einfach. Wenn es richtig schlecht ist, dann nicht drauf zu hauen, sehr, sehr schwierig. Aber es gibt manche Fanszenen, die es schaffen. Und wenn du dir anguckst, Werder Bremen hat mindestens einmal in den letzten drei Jahren den Abstieg verhindert, weil die Fans hinter der Mannschaft standen. Der VfB Stuttgart hat das zweimal geschafft. Dann sind sie trotz eines guten Fan-Zusammenhalts runtergegangen. Da hat aber auch so ein blödsinniges Montagsspiel auswärts bei Bremen noch eine Rolle gespielt, die immer ein bisschen unterschlagen wird. Aber das war ein ganz anderer Umgang.
St. Pauli hat es auch zweimal geschafft.
St. Pauli auch. Das ist doch schon interessant, oder?
Das ist interessant auf jeden Fall. Es ist aber eine Eigenart und ich glaube auch, dass du das niemals… Das ist halt so ein bisschen auch die Einstellungssache. Ich glaube St. Pauli und auch Union, die haben ja wirklich auch so in ihrem… Das ist so ein bisschen ihr Credo, dass Union, ich glaube die pfeifen einfach nie. Oder die würden nie… Ich weiß nicht, ob die die Mannschaft mal auspfeifen. Ich habe es relativ selten, aber ich glaube nicht. Und auch diese plakativen Sprüche, wir wollen euch kämpfen, sehen und so. Also für uns Spieler ist das halt manchmal das Schlimmste. Als Fan singt man das wahrscheinlich relativ gerne mal schnell, weil man denkt, das bringt irgendwas, aber das habe ich nie verstanden, was das bringen soll. Auch wenn es manchmal nicht so aussieht – also ich kann das zumindest für mich sagen, es gibt bestimmt Mannschaften, die haben mal gegen den Trainer gespielt oder so. Aber du versuchst halt schon immer, das zu machen, was in deiner Macht steht. Und manchmal, an manchen Tagen ist es eben nicht genug. Und an manchen Tagen sieht es vielleicht auch nicht so aus, als wenn du es machst. Aber du machst es, aber du bist einfach, wie ich dir gesagt habe, gelähmt von dieser Situation. Und du kannst es nicht so machen, wie du es wolltest. Aber das versteht eben keiner. Und das führt natürlich immer dazu, dass es überhaupt nicht besser werden kann. Also das kann fast nicht besser werden nach solchen, wenn du so Erlebnisse hast. Aber groteskerweise hat uns diese Spielunterbrechung ja geholfen. Irgendwie auf irgendeine Art und Weise.
Genau, ihr kommt zum 2 zu 2 zurück innerhalb von sechs Minuten.
Das war dann nochmal so ein Stimmungsmoment, der hat wieder herangereicht. Aber das war so ein Gemisch aus Hass und Wut und an dieses DFB-Vokalspiel nochmal zurück. Also das war dann, wir haben glaube ich innerhalb von fünf Minuten zwei Tore gemacht. Und das war nochmal eine Stimmung unfassbar. Da hast du wieder gemerkt, ey, die brauchen nur so einen Funken Hoffnung und die sind wieder komplett da. Und wir waren aber gar nicht in der Lage, wir wurden dann ausgekontert. Wir machen es 2-2 und es reicht, sonst wurden wir ausgekontert zu einem 3-2.
Direkt danach.
Direkt danach und danach. Also das waren, weiß ich noch, danach, welche Minute war das Tor?
71. war dann das 3-2.
Die schlimmsten Minuten meines Fußballerlebens danach. Also ich weiß noch, wir waren dann hinten noch zu zweit oder zu dritt. Und ich weiß, ich habe eins gegen eins in der gesamten Hälfte gespielt. Die haben natürlich einen Konter nach dem anderen gefahren. Wir sind nur noch wild angelaufen, ohne Kopf, ohne alles, einfach nur wild. Und ich weiß noch, mit Tat alles weh. Ich konnte mich nicht mehr bewegen. Ich konnte nicht mehr sprinten. Es war wie gelebt alles wirklich. Und ich glaube, ich wurde dann ausgewechselt in der 81. oder 80. Und ich habe mir das dann von draußen nochmal angeguckt.
So eine Auswechslung ist dann…
Also ich weiß nicht, ob sich das jetzt scheiße anhat, aber irgendwie war es eine Art von einer Lösung, weil ich war einfach am Ende. Also ich war am Ende meiner Kräfte und ich hatte nichts mehr zu geben, was irgendwie zu etwas Positives geführt hätte. Also da war nichts mehr drin. Und ja, dann ist es auch so geblieben. Also wir hatten noch Chancen über Chancen, Konterchancen. Und wir hatten nichts mehr, keine nennenswerte Chance mehr. Und dann war das Spiel vorbei. Und dann war ja so 15 Minuten absolute Leere. Also ich habe dann auf der Bank gesessen. Ich bin auch sitzen geblieben, bestimmt 20 Minuten oder so. Und habe einfach mit Kay umgesprochen. Habe einfach noch geradeaus geguckt. Habe versucht, das irgendwie einzuordnen. Aber ging gar nicht. Also da waren so viele wirre Gedanken im Kopf. Und ich habe alles mögliche Gedanken gemacht. Und bin aber zu gar keinem Ziel. Das war wie so ein, du hast dann irgendwas gedacht, dann war wieder was anderes. Also es war ein ganz unwirkliches Gefühl. Und dann hatte ich noch dazu…
Ja, plötzlich nach Schock.
Schockstarre, so ein bisschen genau. Man hat die Fenster hingesehen. Dann haben die dieses Banner da ausgerollt, 60 Minuten die Stadt. Aber das habe ich in dem Moment gar nicht mitbekommen. Ich habe das gelesen, aber irgendwie auch… Also ich habe es nicht wahrgenommen. Ich habe es kurz gelesen und war mir aber nicht egal. Aber ich habe einfach… Ich war in meinem Tunnel irgendwie und habe da gesessen und dann kam jemand.
Ist das nicht auch schon krass, so einen Banner mitzubringen? Also ich finde, dass es dieses Banner gab, das kennzeichnet ja ganz gut das, was du vorher beschrieben hast mit dem Fanspalier, wo du nicht wusstest, ist das Aufmunterung oder Einschüchterung.
Das spiegelt auch das wieder, was ich dir gesagt habe, dass wir nicht das Vertrauen in uns hatten und sie hatten es auch nicht in uns. Weil sonst machst du ja so ein Plakat davor nicht. Das muss ja schon gemacht werden davor quasi. Das hat ja keiner dahin gepinselt, nachdem das Spiel vorbei war. Ich glaube auch, dass es im Endeffekt für den Verein, auch wenn jetzt wahrscheinlich einige sagen werden, ein Abstieg ist nie gut, aber ich glaube, das war gut für den Verein, weil danach hat er sich wieder neu aufgestellt. Die ganzen sozusagen Söldner, die in den Augen der Fans da waren, waren dann weg. Die Verträge waren ungültig und man konnte mit jungen Spielern neu aufbauen. Ich glaube, dass es der Verein sogar jetzt im Endeffekt besser dasteht, als er dastehen würde, wenn wir drin geblieben wären. Bin ich für eigentlich fest der Meinung. Auch wenn sich das jetzt vielleicht für den Verein oder für einige Fans, die das hören würden, blöd anhört, aber ich glaube, dass es wirklich so ist.
Und du hast das mit dem Banner nicht so genau mitbekommen?
Ich habe es mitbekommen, aber viele wussten ja auch gar nicht, für wen das bestimmt war. Da haben mich Bielefeldfans fragen, haben mich dann noch Jahre danach gefragt, war das jetzt für uns als für unsere Mannschaft, dass wir gehen sollten? Oder ganz viele haben das auch so falsch interpretiert. Ich dachte mir von Anfang an, dass das nur für uns gemeint war. Das ist ja klar. Warum soll das für Bielefeld? Das interessiert ja dann im Endeffekt relativ wenig. Da ist ja nur die eigene Mannschaft interessant.
Das war ja letztlich dein Abschied von Dynamo. Es ging ja dann zu Bielefeld. War das auch der Abschied-Abschied? Hattest du noch mal irgendwie andere Begegnungen mit Fans, mit Einzelnen oder mit Mehreren?
Oder war es auch tatsächlich so, dass es das letzte was geblieben ist? Ich hatte dann Doping an dem Tag. Also ich weiß nicht, ob man da nicht mal sagen kann.
Also Doping-Kontrolle?
Ja, Doping-Kontrolle. Das war natürlich irgendwie unwirklich. Man ist mit denen, die haben sich natürlich gefreut. Ohnehin, die Bielefelder mit zweien, die haben da Bier gesoffen. Und wir haben da, Benny Kirsten und ich, hatten Doping. Und es war so eine komische Stimmung. Ich habe auch sogar ein bisschen, glaube ich, teilweise mal mit den Bielefeldern ein bisschen gescherzt. Aber es war so, ich konnte das alles noch nicht greifen. Ich weiß nicht, wenn mich einer gesehen hätte, hätte er gedacht, ey, weiß der nicht, dass die abgestiegen sind gerade? Aber das war so, ich hatte das noch nicht realisiert irgendwie. Das war alles ganz komisch. Und dann war ich irgendwann fertig mit der Doping-Probe und in die Kabine. Und dann kam die Ansage, ja, ihr müsst hier bleiben. Das geht nicht, das ist alles zu gefährlich. Ihr könnt noch nicht nach Hause gehen und so. Die sind wuchsdeufelswild, die Fans. Und ihr müsst jetzt noch bleiben. Wir sagen euch Bescheid, wenn ihr gehen könnt. Und dann haben Fielo, Penny Kirsten und ich ein bisschen zusammengesessen. Und wir haben dann gesagt, das geht nicht. Wir können uns nicht diktieren lassen, wann ich nach Hause gehen kann. Also ich gehe jetzt da raus und gehe jetzt nach Hause. Und wenn mich da jemand anspricht, dann spreche ich mit dem. Und wenn nicht, dann gehe ich halt einfach. Also was soll passieren?
Hattest du keine Angst, dass es noch mehr Eskalierten handgreiflich wird?
Nein, weil ich die Fans trotzdem immer als so kennengelernt habe. Die wollten einfach, dass du dich stellst. Also dass du den Rädern in Antwort stehst. Und wenn du das gemacht hast und ehrlich mit denen warst, dann haben die das akzeptiert. Und so war es dann im Endeffekt auch. Ich bin rausgegangen. Und die waren sauer auf jeden Fall. Die waren super sauer, aber die wollten einfach mit jemandem reden. Die wollten auch ihren Frust irgendwie loswerden. Und das war eigentlich in überraschender Weise ein gutes Gespräch. Weil ich dann gemerkt habe, dass sich die Wut auch viel auf die Franzosen gerichtet hat. Die haben gesagt, die wussten nicht, worum es geht. Und ich war trotzdem nicht ein Junge aus der Region. Die haben mich nicht als Einheimischer betrachtet. Ich war zwar 50 Kilometer entfernt, aber ich war jetzt für die kein dresdner Junge. Aber dann haben mir auch viele gesagt, es wäre schön, wenn du bleibst.
Das hört sich doch auch nach Sündenbock an.
Ja, klar. Ich habe zu denen auch gesagt, ihr braucht euch gar nicht darauf einschießen. Das haben wir alle verbockt zusammen. Das sind jetzt weder die Franzosen noch irgendetwas anderes. Aber die wollten, dass die nachher verschwinden. Die haben dann auch gesagt, es wäre schön, wenn du bleibst. Das war sehr schwer.
Ich habe gesagt, das passt auch in ein vorgezeichnetes Bild von Dynamo Dresden-Fans ganz gut rein.
Aber wie gesagt, es war weniger schlimm als gedacht.
War es für die Franzosen auch weniger schlimm als gedacht?
Nein, die sind wirklich lange drin geblieben. Die hatten auch Angst. Die sind wirklich in der Kabine geblieben und haben dann gewartet.
Das ist doch mega scheiße. Und das ist doch genau so ein Moment, wo man dann vielleicht sagen müsste. Ich will euch das jetzt nicht vorwerfen, weil das war ein Schockerlebnis. Aber eigentlich, wenn man es jetzt im Nachhinein nochmal – wir setzen uns nochmal in die Situation rein, müsste man noch sagen, eigentlich müsste man gemeinsam als Mannschaft mit den Franzosen rausgehen.
Aber das ist dann eben wieder der Fußball. Die schlechte Seite am Fußball, da stirbt eben dann wieder jeder für sich nachher. Im Nachhinein im Erfolg feierst du zusammen, aber nachher war es dann wirklich so, dass das jeder mit sich selbst ausgemacht hat. Und ehrlich gesagt habe ich in dem Moment gar nicht an sowas gedacht, was du gerade gesagt hast, weil ich hatte einfach in meinem Kopf gar keinen Platz für sowas. Aber es wäre vielleicht ein Zeichen gewesen, wenn wir alle zusammen als Mannschaft rausgegangen wären und dann zusammengegangen wären. Aber es hat auch für uns als Truppe quasi nicht gesprochen, dass wir es halt nicht gemacht haben. Also es war halt ein Symbol, dass wir keine Mannschaft waren sozusagen. Dass wir nur ein Haufen von Leuten waren, die Qualität hatten, aber die es eben nicht zusammen auf dem Platz bekommen haben.
Ich muss sagen, ich finde das fast schlimmer als das Plakat. Ich war nie ein Fan dieses Plakats. Ich habe mir damals schon gedacht, was das auch für eine Haltung gegenüber den Menschen, die ja in den Spielern drinstecken, symbolisiert. Das ist ein Umgang mit Menschen, den ich auf keiner Ebene gut finde. Und jetzt aber das im Nachhinein zu hören, dass dann da Sündenböcke gesucht werden, die vielleicht zufällig, vielleicht aber auch nicht zufällig Ausländer sind.
Ja, wie gesagt, es waren bestimmt auch Leute, nicht nur die Franzosen, sondern auch Leute, die von woanders gekommen sind, denen man dann vielleicht vorgeworfen hat, die waren nur ausgeliehen oder so und die haben nicht alles gegeben. Aber wie gesagt, die haben schon ein gutes Gespür gehabt, dass wir wirklich nicht funktioniert haben als Mannschaft. Und die Geschichte am Ende war, dass wirklich jeder Spieler einzeln mit Polizei-Eskort nach Hause gefahren wurde. Ich wurde zu Hause abgeliefert. Mein Kumpel hat mich abgeholt, bin selbst nach Hause gefahren, Polizei ist mit vor meine Haustür gekommen und erst als ich drin gewunken habe und die wussten, dass ich zu Hause sicher angekommen bin, sind die so in Angst hatten, dass da irgendwas passiert. Seitdem ich gesagt habe, ich bin rausgegangen und habe versucht, da war die Angst weg, weil ich gemerkt habe, dass die einfach auch nur reden wollten. Dass die einfach nur mal jemanden haben wollten, dem sie erzählen können, wie die Schlechte sich fühlen. Deswegen war ein unrühmliches Ende. Wirklich so etwas, was man nie wieder erleben will, so ein Abstieg. Vor allen Dingen mit so einem Traditionsverein, wo so viel dranhängt, das ist schon ein entscheidendes Erlebnis.
Du bist dann von Dresden weggewechselt, aber hast du vielleicht abschließend zum Kapitel Dresden das Gefühl, dass es ein paar Prozesse in Gang gesetzt hat? Jetzt nicht nur sportlich, wo du gesagt hast, der Abstieg hat vielleicht sogar gut getan, sondern dass man sich auch damit auseinandergesetzt hat, wie sich da die Fans zum Mannschaftsverhalten haben, die Mannschaft gegenüber den Fans, welche Ressentiments da vielleicht auch geschürt wurden.
Ich hoffe, ich bin natürlich nicht mehr so nah dran jetzt. Ich kenne natürlich noch Leute in Dresden, habe auch noch einen guten Kontakt zu denen, aber so nah bin ich jetzt auch nicht, dass ich das sagen kann. Ich hoffe, dass es, ich meine, die hatten jetzt natürlich seitdem relativ viel Erfolg, seit den Jahren. Also das war jetzt keine wirkliche Riesen-Krisensituation, die man überstehen musste. Und das wird sich dann halt zeigen. Und ich sage auch nicht nur, dass das, wie du gesagt hast, wir hätten als Mannschaft natürlich auch viel mehr machen können noch und viel mehr machen müssen auch, um diesen Bund mit den Fans stärker herzustellen. Das müssen wir uns auch ganz klar inkreiten in dem Moment. Und ich hoffe, dass das keiner der beiden Parteien mehr zulässt, dass das sowohl die Mannschaft dann nicht zulassen würde, als auch die Fans, dass es noch mal so ein Nicht-Vertrauensverhältnis gibt. Also ich hoffe, ich kann es wirklich nicht sagen, aber ich hoffe, dass da jeder natürlich irgendwie seine Lehren draus gezogen hat, sowohl wir als Spieler als auch die Fans.
Und jetzt das Kapitel Aminia Bielefeld. Mein Gott, da haben wir eigentlich noch viel zu besprechen, Sebastian. Es ist erstaunlich, wie man dann vom Hötchen aufs Stöckchen kommt. Wie kam es denn überhaupt dazu, zu Bielefeld zu wechseln? Und was war das dann für eine Zeit für dich da?
Das war irgendwie ganz komisch, weil Norbert Maier hat natürlich – ich hatte ja schon mal gesagt, dass ich heute nach Düsseldorf gehen könnte. Also da hat er anscheinend schon mal ein Auge auf mich geworfen gehabt. Aber groteskerweise war es halt genau dieses letzte Spiel, was ihm dazu gewogen hat, mich zu holen, weil ich da eigentlich ganz ordentlich gespielt habe und auch einen Lattenfreistoß hatte und auch bis zu meiner körperlichen komplett Erschöpfung dann zum Schluss eigentlich ein ordentliches Spiel gemacht habe noch. Und so kam es dann, dass er mich angerufen hat. Und im Urlaub, also das war dann natürlich im Urlaub gefahren, kein Verein. Also Vertrag läuft aus. Klar, bei Dynamo war es völlig unklar, wie es weitergeht. Die haben halt gesagt, eigentlich würden sie schon, aber wir müssen noch abwarten. Ich hatte gerade meine Tochter, die war gerade geboren in dem Jahr 2014. Ich wollte dann natürlich auch eine gewisse Art und Weise von Sicherheit haben. Das Training hat schon fast begonnen und ich hatte immer noch keinen Verein. Im Urlaub hat mich dann Norbert Meyer angerufen. Ich kannte den natürlich, fand den auch immer ganz cool. Ehrlich gesagt, so ein bisschen so ein eigener Typ. Mochte man den jetzt oder mochte man den nicht, muss man mit sich selbst ausmachen. Aber ich fand, dass er halt irgendwie ein Typ war. Seine Kopfnusssache, das war dann schon Ewigkeiten her. Da hat er sich auch wieder erholt gehabt davon, glaube ich.
Da muss man auch irgendwann mal aufhören.
Deswegen fand ich den echt einen charismatischen Typen. Es sollte sich auch rausstellen, dass ich mit ihm gut klarkam. Dann ging es nach Bielefeld, das war für Dresdner Fans nicht so richtig nachzuvollziehen, weil der Verein dann noch abgestiegen ist. Die sind in der Relegation in diesem epischen Match gegen Darmstadt doch noch abgestiegen. Da gab es quasi dieselbe Stimmung wie in Dresden. Da war auch komplett Niedergeschlagenheit. Der Trainer hat mir dann gesagt, du glaubst nicht, hier ist super Aufbruchstimmung. Die Leute sind wieder hinterher und die wollen uns unterstützen. Die wollen, dass wir wieder aufsteigen. Ich sagte kurzum, ich will nichts anderes als wieder hoch mit der Mannschaft. Wir werden eine gute Mannschaft haben, sagte er. Da musste er mir auch vertrauen. Ich kann dir jetzt nicht sagen, wir werden alles holen, aber wir werden eine schlagkräftige Truppe haben. Du sollst ein wichtiger Spieler davon sein, weil du bist erfahren. Du bist schon ein paar Mal aufgestiegen. Ich bin davon überzeugt. Dann war ich auch relativ schnell Feuer und Flamme dafür. Und dann ging es los. Alle Trainer haben gesagt, Bielefeld ist ganz klar die beste Mannschaft. Wir hatten dann so Leute wie Florian Dick geholt, auch mit knapp 250 Spielen in der zweiten Liga. Klosi ist geblieben vorne. Wir haben dann noch so Leute wie Boerner, Hemmlein, wichtige Leute geholt, Dennis Mast noch geholt und Jungler erst später. Pascal Testroth hatten wir noch.
Pierre Kluge hat dann noch ein paar Spiele gemacht.
Pierre Kluge kam noch dazu. Daniel Brinkmann war Star-Einkauf. Das waren ganz erfahrene Spieler. Der Trainer ist ein Typ, der auch auf erfahrene Spieler steht und der das gern hat. Dementsprechend schleppend ging es auch wieder los. Das erste Spiel kann ich mich noch erinnern, Mainz 2. Wir hatten eine super Vorbereitung gespielt und wir waren schon relativ eng zusammengewachsen. Dann haben die uns Mainz 2 komplett hergespielt. Wir wussten nicht, wo vorne und hinten ist, aber wir haben das Spiel gewonnen. 2-1, vollkommen glücklich, zwei Chancen, zwei Tore. Genau, das hat relativ gut angefangen. Das war mal wohltuend, dass der Anfang richtig gut war. Das hatte ich damals nicht so oft, das war ein guter Start für eine super Saison. Dann haben wir direkt zu Hause 5-1 verloren, das erste Spiel. Da dachte ich auch, was soll das werden? Wie in den Halleschen FC. Genau, dann haben wir in Chemnitz 0-0 gespielt, auch völlig glücklich. Dann haben wir nochmal zu Hause gegen Osnabrück verloren 2-1. Dann war die Stimmung wieder ab dem absoluten Tiefpunkt. Da waren die Fans fuchsdeufels wild. Ich dachte, was ist hier los? Die ganze Geschichte geht schon wieder los. Dann kam wieder der DFB-Pokal, die erste Runde, wo ich gern mal ein Tor schieße. Ich ging zu Hause gegen Sandhausen. Da haben wir uns dann mal die Brust frei geschossen. Dann haben wir vielleicht 4-1 gewonnen. Ich habe es 1-0 gemacht und sollte der Auftakt zu einem legendären Pokalauftritt sein in der Saison. Ich war auch der Dosenöffner für die gesamte Saison, weil danach lief es wie am Schnürchen. Das war dann, wo ich dir vorhin erzählt habe, zu Hause haben wir einfach alles weggebeamt, was uns in den Weg gestellt wurde. Also zweite Mannschaften haben alles gewonnen, auch die wichtigen Spieler haben alle zu Hause gewonnen. Pokal gegen Hertha, zweite Runde, schwieriges Spiel, 0-0. Aber wir waren die bessere Mannschaft im ganzen Spiel über. Das war auch Wahnsinn. Wir haben da wirklich nicht mit Glück diese Spiele gewonnen. Also du brauchst auch Glück, na klar. Aber wir waren in diesen Spielen so überzeugt davon, dass wir das gewinnen konnten. Das war Wahnsinn. Wir wussten, wenn Bayern oder Dortmund nicht der Gegner ist, das haben wir uns immer gesagt, dann können wir das schaffen, weil wir waren eine Truppe gemacht für so einen Poker. Wir konnten super umschalten. Wir hatten hinten relativ erfahrene Leute, wir haben gut gestanden und haben super umgeschalten mit schnellen Leuten. Und hatten den dicken Klosi vorne, der dann die Bälle festgemacht hat. Wir waren wie gemacht, um so eine Mannschaften zu ärgern. Und war dann halt auch so härter im Elfmeterschießen. Da waren wir auch – ich habe mit Bielefeld bestimmt sechs Elfmeterschießen gehabt. Wir haben alle gewonnen oder fünf.
Alex Schwolo immer.
Wir hatten erstens einen super Deuter, der immer der Elfer gehalten hat. Genau, Alex Schwolo. Und wir hatten einen super Elfmeterschützen wirklich. Ich habe sowas auch noch nie gesehen. Wir hatten David Ulm. Der hat in Thomas Müller Manier ausgeguckt, also der Klosi ausgeguckt. Die haben nie verschossen. Also die haben so gut wie nie einen Elfmeter verschossen beide. Und dann hatten wir noch so zwei, drei, die gesagt haben, wir fühlen uns gut.
Welcher Schütze wärst du gewesen?
Also da kommen wir noch aufs Gladbach-Spiel nachher dazu. Und er hat gewonnen, okay, das war dann gut. Und dann wurde Bremen ausgelost und unser Platz war da, weiß ich noch, das war dann immer Sinnbild der Diskussion. Bremen hat gesagt, auf so einem Platz können wir nicht spielen. Die haben sich natürlich alle tierisch aufgeregt. Und für uns war es natürlich klar aus fußballerischer Sicht, dass es viel leichter auf einem schlechten Platz umzuschalten, als das Spiel machen zu müssen. Das war uns klar. Und dementsprechend war es dann auch Bremen. Die Stimmung in den Spielen war Wahnsinn wirklich. Also das Bielefelder Publikum, das war unfassbar, wirklich was da für Stimmung geherrscht hat. Und Bremen haben wir völlig verdient auch 3-1 geschlagen. 3-1, ne? Auch wieder ein Tor gemacht. Nach einem Standard, genau. Einfach. Das war so ein Tor, das musste einfach passieren. Das war für die Ecke, wie im Intro besprochen, Christian Müller macht die Beine breit, lässt ihn durch. Das ist einfach nur ein Fuß reingehalten. Das war keine Schusstechnik, einfach nur ein Schienbeinschoner reingehalten. Und drin war das Ding. Das war irgendwie so, das musste passieren an dem Tag irgendwie. Weiß ich auch nicht. Das war einfach…
Da hat der Sky-Kommentator – habe ich leider nur in schlechter Audioqualität gefunden, deswegen hat es nicht ins Intro geschafft. Andreas Renner war das, glaube ich. Er hat gesagt, das sah aber nach einer einstudierten Variante aus. Arminia Bielefeldt TV stellt dir die Frage. Und war das einstudiert? Und du sagst, wie soll man denn so etwas einstudieren? Da müssen ja gleich mal zwei Leute schnarchen, damit das klappt, fand ich irgendwie nett.
Ja, das war wirklich… Also wir waren super bei Standards. Wir haben in der ganzen Saison, ich glaube, 50, 60 Prozent unserer Tore durch Standards gemacht. Wir waren Florian Dicky, ich glaube, da hatte 18 Assists in dem Jahr oder so. Das war Wahnsinn. Also der musste die Dinger nur reinhauen. Wir hatten in der Mitte Klosi, Boerner, ich, wir haben beide, wir haben alle drei bestimmt vier, fünf Standard-Tore gemacht. Und das war ein Dosenöffner für richtig auch in der Liga dann halt. Und so etwas konnte man natürlich da nicht einstudieren. Das war eigentlich eine schlechte Ecke, die einfach nur am ersten Pfosten durchgelassen wurde. Halb flach und keiner hat den… Ich weiß noch genau, da hat mich Garcia gedeckt von Bremen in dem Spiel. Und der wurde ausgewechselt vor der Ecke und der hat mich davor die Standards… Also so gut hat mich noch nie einer verteidigt. Ich hatte keinen Millimeter Raum gehabt. Der hat mich einfach kaltgestellt, wirklich. Und der wurde dann gelb-rot gefärdet ausgewechselt genau vor der Ecke. Da kam Sternberg rein, weiß ich noch. Und da war ich dann frei wie ein Vogel und konnte mich bewegen, wie ich wollte.
Und dann war er. Und dann macht Junglas noch zum Schluss einen Konter, 3-1. Und dann waren wir im Viertelfinale. Da haben wir dann schon ein bisschen angefangen zu überlegen. Da haben wir gesehen, wer noch drin war. Und das war so eine Saison, wo es gar keine Überraschungen gab. Da waren nur wir und sonst nur die Belletage des deutschen Fußballs. Dortmund, Bayern, Gladbach, Wolfsburg, Schalke. Nein, Schalke, das ging Dynamo rausgeflogen, glaube ich. Also wirklich nur noch gute Mannschaften. Freiburg war noch drin und wir dachten, wenn wir Freiburg zuhause kriegen, wäre geil. Aber dann ist es Gladbach geworden und die waren ja in dem Jahr auch super. Da war Kruse, Traurig, Chaka Kramer, die hatten eine super Mannschaft. Da dachten wir dann schon, da brauchen wir einen außergewöhnlichen Tag, um die zu schlagen. Und den hatten wir dann auch wieder wirklich unfassbar gut, wie wir da gespielt haben. Ich weiß noch, Klaus Alofs, nein, Klaus Alofs nicht, der war Aichin von Bremen. Er hat gesagt, ich garantiere, hier scheidet noch eine andere Mannschaft aus. Wir waren einfach stark, wir haben nicht nur gekämpft und uns mit Glück irgendwie, wir haben dann super gespielt und hatten super Passagen drin, die dem Gegner richtig wehgetan haben und so auch Gladbach. Wir haben 1-0 geführt in der ersten Halbzeit, Junglas auch wieder, super Tor, dann kriegen wir ein Handelfmeter-Krusel, macht das Ding rein und dann 1-1. Wir haben hinten immer super gestanden. Ich weiß noch Patrick Herrmann, ich muss gegen Hermann spielen, den hatte ich relativ gut im Griff. Der wurde dann ausgewechselt und dann siehst du natürlich, selber meine Zunge hing schon hier unten in der 70. Dann kommt Traoré rein. Da dachte ich schon, der hat richtig Bock zu klickern und lächeln. Der war auch richtig agiert, der ist immer nach innen und hat geschossen, geschossen, aber nicht getroffen. Dann merkt man halt die Situation. Ich weiß noch, das werde ich nie vergessen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das einer gesehen hat. Ich habe in einem brutalen Tunnel gespielt gegen Kramer. Dann kommt Traoré den Ball ab, dann kommt Kramer angestürzt, durchgeschoben, weiter Riesenkontakt und Riesenchance. An dem Moment wusste ich auch, wir gewinnen das Ding heute wieder. Wir waren einfach alle davon überzeugt. Deswegen haben wir es auch immer geschafft. Wenn du diese Überzeugung in so einem Pokal spielst, dann schaffst du es auch nicht. Wir schießen fünf Schützen rum und entschieden, sechster Schütze war noch relativ klar, dass da einer geht. Ich weiß nicht, war sechster Schütze schon Bormast? Felix Bormast, genau. Unsere fünf Schützen standen fest. Die waren in Stein gemeißelt. Ulm, Klos, Brinkmann. Dick hat gechipt. Lorenz hatte das entscheidende Tor gegen Dings gemacht. Lorenz musste nur noch treffen, der fünfte Schütze. Dann wären wir schon weiter gewesen, verschießt. Dann ging es im Mittelkreis los. Wir standen da, uns alle. Jeder hat gesagt, dass wir drei Schützen waren, die uns gesagt haben, dass wir den reinmachen. Wir haben uns alle gegründet. Wir haben Felix Boweister genötigt zu schießen. Wir haben gesagt, Felix, komm, du machst das Ding heute rein.
Du hast ein gutes Gefühl.
Der war nicht überzeugt davon.
Danke, mein Mann.
Wirklich. Keiner war davon überzeugt von uns. Aber Felix hat das Ding reingehauen. Dann haben Hemmlein und ich uns angeguckt. Wir sind richtig gute Kumpels. Wir haben dann gleichzeitig zueinander gesagt, du schießt den Ding. Ich weiß nicht, was passiert wäre. Ich bin heute Alex Schwolo noch dankbar und traurig, dass er den verschossen hat und Alex den gehalten hat. Ich weiß nicht, was passiert wäre. Da kommt auch der Aberglaube durch. Wir haben es so oft davor geschafft. Ich dachte, ich kann heute nicht, ich wollte auch nicht schießen. Irgendeiner muss ja der sein, der verschießt. Aber ich dachte einfach, es ist nicht nötig, dass ich schieße. Wir kommen auch so weiter. So war es dann zum Glück auch, dass ich nicht schießen musste.
Vielleicht ist dir da auch einer der größten Momente deiner Karriere entgangen. Du hättest auch der Schütze sein können, der mit dem Schuss in den Winkel…
Aber das war auch unsere Mannschaft so ein bisschen. Das hat unsere Mannschaft ausgezeichnet. Da war gar keiner so, der immer im Rampenlicht sein wollte, sondern wir waren so eine geile Truppe. Der Trainer Norbert Meyer war für mich immer mein bester Trainer in meiner ganzen Laufbahn. Einfach so, weil er so viel wusste, wie er uns anzufassen hat. Der wusste, wann er draufhauen musste, wann er lange Leine lassen musste. Perfekt wirklich. Der war für unsere Mannschaft der perfekte Trainer. Deswegen war es auch nicht so, dass da immer einer im Rampenlicht stehen wollte, sondern Felix hat es dann an dem Tag genommen und Alex hat es dem gehalten. Und fertig, möglich.
Und dann Halbfinale gegen den VfL.
Dann musst du erstmal die Auslosung abwarten. Dortmund, Bayern, Wolfsburg waren noch in der Lostoffe. Ich habe immer im Pokal gehofft, bitte nicht Bayern, bitte nicht. Ich will nicht bei Guardiola die ganze Zeit hinterher rennen und dann acht Stück kriegen und du bist zwölf Kilometer hinterher gerannt. Darauf hatte ich wirklich keiner Bock. Das war Dortmunds Jahr. Wir wollten eigentlich alle Dortmund haben, weil das Dortmunds Jahr war, wo die nicht so gut waren, wo die unten gestanden haben. Wir dachten, wenn wir von denen einschlagen können, dann ist Dortmund zu Hause. Wir waren sicher, dass wir zu Hause spielen, weil wir Drittligist waren. Dann ist es aber Wolfsburg geworden und das war ein Spiel. Die haben uns nicht unterschätzt, sondern sie haben uns an dem Tag zerstört. Sie haben von der ersten Sekunde lang nicht den Hauch eines Zweifels aufkommen lassen, dass sie uns heute hier schlagen und auch in relativ klarer Art und Weise. Das hätte in den anderen Spielen auch passieren können, wenn der Bundesligis dann einmal 1-0 führt. Das ist natürlich relativ schwer. Vor allen Dingen so eine Mannschaft, die waren ja dann dem Jahr richtig gut und die hatten einfach Selbstvertrauen ohne Ende.
Haben wir den Pokal dann auch geholt, das war ja die Saison.
Genau. Man hat schon gemerkt, bei der Erwärmung bis zum Viertelfinale war es nur relativ gediegen. Klar war die Medienpräsenz schon ein bisschen höher, aber wenn du dann halt Scholl und Beckmann an der Seite stehend siehst, weil es war dann ein AD-Livespiel.
Kann man nicht ausblenden, ne?
Kannste nicht ausblenden. Bei der Erwärmung guckst du dann hoch und dann dachtest du schon, oh, okay, heute ist wirklich was Besonderes. Und als Drittligis im Halbfinale zu stehen war schon was Besonderes, muss man wirklich sagen. Obwohl die uns dann auch komplett auseinandergenommen haben, hat es einfach Spaß gemacht, das Spiel wirklich. Also das war die beste 4-0-Niederlage meines Lebens, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Weil relativ zeitig klar war, dass wir es nicht schaffen werden. 2-0, dann war es dann vorbei. Aber es hat trotzdem Spaß gemacht irgendwie, weil die Fans, die haben uns dann gefeiert nach dem Spiel. Das war eine Stimmung, unfassbar, als ob wir 4-0 gewonnen hatten. Das war wirklich Wahnsinn. Das hatte ich so noch nicht erlebt, dass man so gefeiert wurde nach so einem Spiel, wo die uns quasi hergespielt haben.
Das war ja auch schon, es war glaube ich noch nicht mathematisch klar, aber relativ sicher, dass ihr auf 5-0 gefeiert habt.
Überhaupt nicht, das war das Problem. Der Pokal hat uns quasi die Liga immer ein bisschen, wir haben immer verloren nach dem Pokal, weil das immer ewig lange Spiele waren.
Weil ihr zu viel gefeiert habt, gibt es doch so.
Auch das, wahrscheinlich. Aber es war halt immer so, dass wir, wenn da jemand hätte richtig Geld verdienen können, und dem ja das immer gesetzt hätte, dass wir verlieren nach dem Pokal spielen. Weil so haben wir halt die Liga unnötig spannend gemacht. Wenn der Pokal nicht gewesen wäre, wären wir wahrscheinlich schon fünf, sechs Spieltage davor aufgestiegen. Aber so haben wir es dann erst am vorletzten Spieltag geschafft, weil wir dann noch zwei, drei Mal unentschieden gespielt haben und wirklich der Tank dann ein bisschen leer war. Wir hatten mit diesem Ollen-Westfalen-Pokal, den wir da auch noch spielen mussten, ich glaube fast 60 Spiele in dem Jahr. Das hat man am Ende schon gemerkt. Und bloß gut haben wir uns dann mit drei unentschieden uns dann irgendwie gemausert da zum Aufstieg und haben dann auch mal das letzte Spiel gewonnen. Und sind dann als Meister aufgestiegen. Und sensationelles Jahr, schönes Jahr meiner Karriere, wirklich nur positive Erlebnisse, nur Erfolg gehabt. Eigentlich das ganze Jahr Wahnsinn, also wirklich. Und im Pokal, das macht ja unheimlich viel Spaß, wenn du da mal wieder spielen kannst und da die Großen ärgern kannst. Das macht unfassbar viel Spaß. Vor allen Dingen, wenn du dann halt auch wirklich ein Paar hintereinander raus haust. Dann siehst du auch wirklich in den Köpfen der Bundesligaspieler, dass dann nachher, dass die halt denken, das wird nicht leicht heute. Das hast du immer gesehen in den Köpfen, dass die wussten, das wird kein Spaziergang.
Und dann steigst du in die zweite Liga auf, in so einer Fußballstadt, wie du gesagt hast, Bielefeld. Wie ist denn Bielefeld, wenn man dort als Spieler ist?
Super, richtig gut. Also das war halt wieder so ein komplettes Kontrastprogramm in Dresden. Die sind eher, was man nicht negativ singen kann, aber die sind eher, so nicht aggressiv, aber die sind offensiv mit dir. Also wenn du in der Stadt bist, dann reden die dich auf jeden Fall an. Und egal, ob du da irgendwo was machst oder nicht, die sprechen dich einfach an. Und Bielefeld sind, du merkst genau, dass die dich immer erkennen, aber die sind sehr zurückhaltend, die lassen dich machen. Und die sind wirklich, die lassen dich eher in Ruhe, als sie dich ansprechen quasi. Und das habe ich halt sehr angenehm empfunden. Vor allen Dingen von Dresden damals, da war es wirklich ein richtiger Kontrast. Und ich habe mich oder wir als Familie, wir haben uns super wohl gefühlt. Also das war ein richtig tolles Umfeld, wo man sich richtig wohlfühlen konnte. Wirklich die gleiche Fußballbegeisterung, aber irgendwie ein anderer Umgang damit. Also ein bisschen anders, die haben eine andere, nicht andere Erwartungshaltung, aber die haben einfach einen anderen Anspruch, sich das geltend zu machen. Die waren ein bisschen ruhiger, die haben gesagt, die machen das schon. Man hatte immer das Gefühl, dass die trotzdem, die waren auch sauer. Und wir hatten auch mal Phasen, wo es nicht lief, wo die richtig angepisst waren natürlich. Aber man hatte irgendwie immer so das Gefühl, dass die uns vertrauen im Endeffekt. Dass sie sagen, wir kennen die Truppe, die sind aufgestiegen, die haben im DFB-Buch halt, das ist eine homogene Truppe und die lösen das schon irgendwie. So hatte ich das oft im Gefühl. Und es hat sich dann irgendwie bewahrheitet. Also irgendwie haben wir diese schwierigen Situationen immer gelöst. Also es war einfach eine wunderbare Zeit gewesen. Also im ersten Jahr waren wir auch relativ gut. Wir waren halt nie richtig im oberen Mittelfeld, aber wir waren immer relativ gesichert und haben es…
Genau, was wir ein bisschen mehr erwarten von einem Aufsteiger. Also in der Super-Saison…
Da hatten wir ein Rekord für Unentschieden aufgestellt. Ich glaube, 18 Unentschieden oder 19 Unentschieden in der Saison.
Ach ja, richtig, das war es. Stimmt. Ja, jetzt sehe ich es gerade auch hier. Richtig, ich erinnere mich.
Das war irgendwie immer so ein bisschen halb voll oder halb leer. Diskussionen, ist das jetzt gut oder ist das nicht gut? Aber es war eben gut, weil wir halt relativ wenig Spiele verloren haben. Also wir haben immer gepunktet irgendwie. Auch wenn es halt nur einfach war, haben wir es trotzdem geschafft, immer irgendwie zu punkten und immer uns diesen nötigen Abstand zu sichern, der uns nicht in diese endgültig prekäre Lage gebracht hat.
Du bist schon vorher bei Dresden, aber jetzt auch in der Saison in Wielefeld auch mal als Kapitän aufgelaufen. Hat dir das was bedeutet?
Also, für mich ist das nicht so wichtig. Also für mich war immer wichtig, dass ich im Mannschaftsrat war, weil ich schon ein Spieler war, der das immer gut umgesetzt hat, was die Mannschaft verlangt hat oder was aus der Mannschaft rauskam und der das gut rüberbringen konnte bei den Offiziellen und bei den Trainern. Weil ich mir da wirklich nicht zu schade war, auch Sachen klar anzusprechen. Also das war mir wichtig. Aber Kapitän sein war jetzt wirklich nicht so glossy in Wielefeld Kapitän. Damit war ich komplett einverstanden. Und in Dresden war Fielo damals und dann Romain Brejerie Kapitän. Also es war jetzt nie so, dass ich irgendwie sage, das hätte ich jetzt irgendwie besser machen können oder das hätte jetzt besser gemacht. Das war alles vollkommen in Ordnung. Deswegen hatte ich da auch nie so das Verlangen. Es war öfter mal so, wie du gesagt hast, dass halt die mal ausgefallen sind und ich dann mal so Ausgiftkapitän war. Aber es war jetzt nie so, dass ich mich danach gesehen habe, da mal Kapitän zu sein. Also es ist schön und gut, aber nichts ist jetzt nichts, was für mich unglaublich wichtig ist.
Nicht schneller gelaufen, das ist okay. Über die Saison kann man recht schnell drüber gehen. Jetzt sind wir dann schon in der Saison 2016, 2017. Das heißt, das liegt jetzt unmittelbar zurück. Das ist deine letzte Saison bei Arminio Bielefeld. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man da Pokal von Bundesliga trennen kann. Also wir alle wissen natürlich, da werden sich auch die Hörerinnen und Hörer dran erinnern, es ging spitz auf Knopf um den Abstieg in den letzten Spielen, den hat man dann aber vermeiden können. Und im Pokal ging es bis ins Viertelfinale, nämlich bis gegen Eintracht Frankfurt. Hängen die beiden Wettbewerber wieder miteinander zusammen, so wie zwei Jahre zuvor? Oder ist es diesmal irgendwie so, naja, ich meine, man gewinnt halt dann auch mal gegen RW Essen und gegen Waldorf.
Ja, das war irgendwie eine ganz eigenartige Saison. Das hatte auch keine so richtige Eigendynamik. Das erste Spiel war einfach auch wieder im Elfer schießen. Da können wir anscheinend nicht verlieren. Das war klar und war ein ekliges Spiel in Essen. Weiß man ja selbst, da ist gute Stimmung und die haben auch keine schlechte Mannschaft gehabt. Das zweite Spiel war in Dresden. Das war der Trainerwechsel, da wurde dann Rüdiger Reben, den wir mit vielen Vorschusslorbeeren verpflichtet hatten, im Sommer schon entlassen. Und da war dann Rumpi, der später dann auch die Ansprache gehalten hat.
Dazu kommen wir noch her.
Und das war ein absoluter Sieg des Willens. In Dresden hat er 15 Mal gegen Latte und Pfosten geschossen. In dem Spiel hat er wirklich eine Chance nach der anderen versiebt. Und wir hatten wirklich nur eine, und die haben wir reingemacht und eins nur gewonnen. Also schmeichelhaft ohne Ende. Aber eben weitergekommen. Und dann war auf Astoria auch wieder ein ekliges Spiel. Wieder Elfer schießen können wir nicht verlieren, anscheinend. Weitergekommen. Und dann ein bisschen schade, dass wir nicht ein Heimspiel hatten. Dann haben wir in Frankfurt gespielt und waren da aber bizarerweise die bessere Mannschaft. Und hätten da wenigstens einen Unentschieden über die normale Spielzeit verdient gehabt, haben wir drei, vier Hunderter zum Schluss liegen lassen. Frankfurt war völlig apathisch. Da ging gar nichts an dem Tag. Und wäre eigentlich auch möglich gewesen, da weiterzukommen. Aber gut, war halt dann nicht so. Und so, wie die Saison war, ist es dann auch ein bisschen leise zu Ende gegangen. Der DFB-Bokal Traum da quasi. Ich weiß nicht, wie in Frankfurt dann in der nächsten Runde. Die waren ja im Finale dann da, den die da gehabt haben.
Wenn das das Viertelfinale war, dann hat in Gladbach in Frankfurt durch ein Elfmeterschießen…
Das war wirklich eine komische Pokalsaison. Wir haben uns da auch nicht hochgeholt für diese Saison. Wir waren da auch nicht so brutal überzeugt davon, wie in dem anderen Jahr. Das war halt einfach so eine eher glückliche Sache, würde ich sagen. Dass wir da so weit gekommen sind.
Und in der Liga immer unten drin, vom 17. Spieltag bis zum 33. Spieltag, immer auf dem Abstiegs- oder Religationsplatz und erst dann am 34. Spieltag, dann sich gerettet auf den 15.
Man muss sagen, wir sind ja mit einer brutalen Hypotheke in die Saison gegangen. Wir haben aus elf Spielen, glaube ich, noch fünf Punkte geholt mit Rüdiger Rehm. Das hat auch aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht gepasst. Er hatte eine andere Art, die wir nicht umsetzen konnten. Das hat wirklich nicht funktioniert. Dann haben sie die Reißleine gezogen und wir sind immer hinterhergerannt. Wenn du nur fünf oder elf Punkte aus elf Spielen holst, dann ist es immer schwer. Wir haben danach eigentlich einen Punkteschnitt gehabt, der, glaube ich, über eine Saison über gereicht hätte. Aber wir hatten immer diesen Rückstand und haben oft zu Hause nur gewonnen und haben auswärts nichts geholt. Und dann kam Jürgen Kramny, der war halt auch eher so ein bisschen alte Schule. Und da hat uns vielleicht noch nicht ganz das gegeben, was wir da irgendwie gebraucht hatten. Wir brauchten einen klaren Plan, den uns nachher auch Serbene gegeben hat, wo wir es dann irgendwie geschafft haben. Und deswegen hat das auch irgendwie nicht geklappt. Und Kramny wurde auch entlassen kurz nach der Winterpause. Und dann kam Jeff Seibene und für mich eher ein düsteres Kapitel nachher im Endeffekt. Aber ich war super froh, dass wir es geschafft haben. Ich habe ein Spiel mit Davy gemacht, da hat er mich nach 60 Minuten rausgeholt. Und danach hat er einfach gesagt, dass er mit mir als Spieler irgendwie nichts anfangen kann, so nach dem Motto. Er hat mich immer genau wissen lassen, was war. Also es war vollkommen in Ordnung. Ich habe auch zu ihm ein ganz normales Verhältnis gesetzt. Wir haben uns letztens gesehen, alles in Ordnung, kein Problem. Aber er konnte einfach mit mir nichts anfangen, was auch in Ordnung war, weil ich war dann wirklich ein brutaler Teamplayer und habe versucht, da für die Mannschaft da zu sein im Training, mich reinzuschmeißen und zu versuchen, irgendwie eine Stütze zu sein in der Situation. Ich glaube, es hat auch ganz gut geklappt. Die Vorgaben, die er gegeben hat, haben gut funktioniert. Wir haben Punkte geholt, wir haben auch nicht so viele gewonnen, aber wir haben auch nicht viel verloren. Wir haben ein paar Unentschieden gespielt und bis zum ominösen Braunschweigspiel am Ende waren wir uns auch nicht sicher, ob wir es schaffen werden. Aber es war zumindest ein bisschen Licht am Ende des Tunnels.
Es war möglich. Und über dieses Braunschweigspiel, da müssen wir sprechen. Denn vor der Partie ist das hier passiert. Ich hole mal alle mit ins Boot.
25.000 sind da draußen und warten darauf, dass ihr gleich explodiert. 25.000! Wir beten zu Gott, dass ihr gleich Gas gebt, dass ihr ein Feuerwerk abfackelt. Aber ein Punkt ist mir noch viel, viel wichtiger, Männer. Wenn ihr nach Hause geht, könnt ihr die ganzen Müll bei euren Frauen, bei euren Kindern, bei euren Freundinnen abladen. Alles, alles was hier passiert, könnt ihr zu Hause abladen. Und wir sind immer für euch da. Immer! Jeden Tag sind sie zu Hause. Und heute sind sie auf der Tribüne und bieten genauso zu kosten, wie die anderen auch, dass ihr heute ein Feuerwerk abfackelt. Und deswegen ist Katrin drin. Und in diesem Video auch. Weil sie das jetzt gleich vor dem Spiel euren Frauen schickt. Und ihr müsst mir jetzt den Versprechen hier leisten, ableisten, dass ihr für eure Familie alles geht. In den 90 Minuten für eure Familie, für eure Kinder, wer jetzt hier draußen ernt kann, von Anfang bis zum Ende. Und wir werden das Spiel gewinnen.
Ich gucke. Hast du Gänsehaut?
Ich habe es schon so oft danach wieder gehört, weil meine Tochter, wenn sie mal ein Handy in der Hand hat, dass sie auch gerne mal anhört, weil sie mich immer fragt, ob der Mann sauer war. Ich habe es schon zu oft gehört. Aber ich habe nur gute Erinnerungen daran auf jeden Fall.
Wie oft funktioniert sowas?
Also bei Rumpi relativ oft. Ich würde nicht mal sagen, dass es seine beste Ansprache war. Er hat wirklich ein brutales Talent dafür, dich zu pushen vor dem Spiel. Mit so Geschichten aus dem Leben, die er so aufgesaugt hat. Manchmal hat er was erzählt von der Fahrt zum Stadion, was er irgendwie gesehen hat und was er umgemünzt hat in so einer Motivationsrede. Er kann das richtig gut, muss ich sagen. Er hat genau gewusst, wo er dich immer packen musste oder wo er uns packen musste. Dass er uns da quasi ein bisschen am Ehrgefühl gepackt hat, für die Familie alles zu geben in dem Moment. Es funktioniert nicht jeden Spieltag, auf keinen Fall. Das kann es nicht machen. Aber er hat schon drei, vier solche Ansprachen gemacht, wo es nachher ähnlich war. Aber es war natürlich dann passend, dass wir noch 6-0 gewonnen haben dazu. Gegen den Tabellen zweiten.
Die sind deswegen letztlich in der Relegation dann gegen Würzburg gelandet. Was ich mich da immer frage, ist, mich nimmt das auch mit. Ich glaube, dieses Video lässt niemanden kalt. Deswegen verbreitet es sich ja auch so weit. Und es ist auch so eine witzige Mischung aus Sparta. Wir sind Sparta und die Kathrin zeigt es gleich euren Freundinnen bei WhatsApp. Da kommt noch so ein multimediale Faktor rein, den ich irgendwie ganz interessant finde. Aber trotzdem ist es ja so, du bist in dem Moment dann auf 180. Alle jubeln sich zu. Und dann gehst du aus der Kabine raus und ja, super motiviert im Gang. Und dann läuft der Schiedsrichter aufs Feld und alle ja, wir machen das. Und dann ja erst nochmal die Kapitäne, Spielfeld, Wahl. Schiedsrichter guckt nochmal auf die Uhr. Geht da nicht auch dieses Adrenalin, diese Motivationskurve sehr schnell wieder runter oder trägt sich das tatsächlich bis zum Anpfiff?
Das trägt sich schon. Also wenn das gut gemacht ist, so wie bei ihm jetzt, dann trägt sich das schon bis zum Anpfiff mit rein. Du machst ja dann nochmal einen Kreis vor dem Anpfiff quasi. Ich habe ja auf der Bank gesessen, deswegen kann ich das nicht genau sagen, aber das pusht dich schon. Also bei ihm, wenn er das gemacht hat, war ich immer vorhanden. Es kann auch sein, dass Spieler davon nicht angesprochen werden, dass du Spieler damit nicht kriegst mit so einer Rede. Mich hat er damit immer gepackt und viele andere auch. Deswegen ist es ja auch was nicht so alltägliches, dass der Co-Trainer das überhaupt machen darf. Dass der Trainer zulässt, dass der Co-Trainer so eine Motivationsrede hält. Weil Trainer dann schon immer denken, dass das ein bisschen ein Autoritätsverlust nachher ist, wenn man den Co-Trainer das machen lässt. Aber da muss man dem Jeff Sabin auch hoch anrechnen, dass er sich da zurückgenommen hat, weil er einfach auch nicht der Typ ist dafür. Weil er eher ein ruhiger Typ ist, ein analytischer Typ ist. Und hätte wahrscheinlich nicht jeder Trainer so gemacht, denke ich, dass er das überhaupt zugelassen hätte. Aber Rumpi hat ein super Talent dafür und deswegen glaube ich, dass er auch mal ein ganz guter Trainer werden wird.
Also das kann man wohl sagen, wenn ich mal irgendjemandem verpflichtet, das Erwerbung für den Rasenfunk mache, dann werde ich bei ihm anrufen. Sollen wir da mal ein Jingle einsprechen und dann hört ganz Deutschland den Rasenfunk entweder aus Angst oder aus Motivation.
Die haben ja sogar eine Werbung draus gemacht. Ich weiß nicht, ob du es gesehen hast, bei Sky Läuft ist ja – ob wir ja keine Schleichwerbung machen, aber für den Sponsor, für Alpezin quasi gibt es einen Denken daran. Musst mal gucken, ob Sky Läuft das bei den Spielen…
Hat er den Professor Dr. Klänk abgelöst?
Nein, das war nicht der, das hat dann der Physio gemacht quasi, aber es ist an die Rede angelehnt. Da haben sie eine ganz coole Werbung gemacht. Es ist echt nicht schlecht gemacht, muss ich sagen. Musst die auch schmunzeln.
Okay, und jetzt sind wir im Hier und Jetzt angekommen, nämlich bei den Würzburger Kickers. Wie kam es, dass du zur Würzburg gewechselt bist? Und jetzt sind wir im Aktuellen. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie viele Phrasen du eigentlich trischst, wenn es nicht um die Retrospektive geht. Wie kam es denn erst mal, dass du hierher gewechselt bist?
Das war ein richtig schwieriger Sommer, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Ich hatte mir das nie so vorgestellt, dass das mal so laufen könnte. Aber es war einfach eine Verkettung unglücklicher Umstände. Der Vertrag läuft aus, du spielst die letzten zehn Spiele nicht. Im Fußball ist es einfach so ein Gesetz. Du kannst selbst die Hinrunde überragend spielen, die Rückrunde zählt. Selbst wenn es nur die letzten zehn Spiele sind und du machst da fünf Tore als Offensivspieler, dann ist das genau das, was allen im Kopf geblieben ist. Ich habe in der Hinrunde relativ gut gespielt, Tore gemacht, Tore vorbereitet, aber nachher hat es keinen mehr interessiert. Das war wirklich die ganzen Zweitligisten. Mein Berater war überall unterwegs, alles abgegrast, sehr, sehr schwer. Er hat gesagt, ich kriege nicht mal richtige Absagen, aber keiner sagt, dass du schlecht bist. Aber entweder wollen alle jüngere Lösungen suchen oder sehen dich da gerade oder brauchen da nichts oder sagen halt, du kannst da in dem Moment vielleicht gerade nicht helfen. Also alles komisch, aber wirklich, ich stand halt dann, das war dann Juli, die haben angefangen zu trainieren, alle Mannschaften. Und ich habe mich dann halt versucht, selbst zu halten. Das war eine komische Situation, ich musste damit auch erst ein bisschen klarkommen. Aber ich war eigentlich immer hoffnungsvoll, dass sich das Karussell noch weiter dreht und was es ja am Endeffekt auch hat. Aber ich wollte eigentlich immer, mein Traum war immer noch mal im Ausland zu spielen und wollte das auch unbedingt verwirklichen. Aber das hat leider nicht so geklappt, Amerika wäre ein Pinzli gewesen. Genau, ich wollte unbedingt nach Amerika, das hat leider nicht geklappt. Da gab es schon mal konkrete Gespräche, aber das hat dann leider nicht geklappt, weil die Mannschaft dann um dies ging. Da hat dann noch mal so ein Siegeszug gestartet und da hat sich das erledigt gehabt mit Spielerverpflichten. Dann kam halt Würzburg und hat gefragt, ob ich mir das vorstellen könnte. Ich hatte bis dato halt wirklich wenig bis gar nichts, was ich machen konnte. Ich war wirklich schon ein bisschen unruhig. Meine Frau hat dann auch mal gesagt, was denkst du denn jetzt, was machen wir denn jetzt? Da war schon selbst ein bisschen Unruhe bei mir dabei. Dann kam der Anruf, ob ich mir das vorstellen könnte und dann ging es eigentlich auch relativ schnell. Interessanterweise haben sich danach noch Optionen aufgetan, als ich bei Würzburg unterschrieben hatte. Komischerweise, wie es manchmal im Leben so ist, wäre alles auf einmal gekommen. Aber so bin ich jetzt trotzdem sehr zufrieden. Ich finde das super interessant, wie das hier abläuft. Der Verein ist halt sehr, sehr schnell hochgekommen. Er ist jetzt leider wieder abgestiegen und versucht jetzt wieder einen Fuß zu fassen mit einem neuen Trainer und einer neuen Mannschaft. Das fand ich immer interessant. Deswegen war es auch immer das Ding, dass ich in die dritte Liga gegangen bin, wenn es so Neuanfänge waren, weil ich da auch ganz gut mithelfen kann, weil ich da mittlerweile auch einen gewissen Erfahrungsschatz habe. Deswegen dachte ich, das könnte interessant werden. So war es dann auch relativ schnell. Ich war dann auch Feuer und Flamme dafür. Ich bin direkt hingeflogen ins Trainingslager und habe dann unterschrieben. Ich spiele jetzt bei den Würzburger Kickers.
Unter dem Trainer Stefan Schmidt hast du die Doku-Trainer gesehen.
Habe ich gesehen.
Welchen Eindruck hast du nach der Doku von Stefan Schmidt gehabt und wie ist er jetzt, wo du ihn wirklich kennst?
Ein komplett Anderen, muss ich sagen. Ich glaube, er weiß auch, dass er da ein bisschen, nicht provokativ, aber sehr forsch daherkommt und ich glaube, dass das auch so sein Ding nach außen ist, dass er da sehr selbstbewusst drüber kommt und sehr fachmännisch. Ich muss aber sagen, dass ich hier sehr angenehm überrascht bin, wie er umgeht mit der Mannschaft, weil er hat super viel Geduld mit den Jungs-Spielern. Wir haben viele junge Spieler und bezieht uns ältere Spieler auch mit ein. Viele Leute haben mir gesagt, man, bist du da überzeugt von dem Trainer? Sie haben sicherlich auch diese Dokumentation im Hinterkopf. Allen, die mir das sagen, sage ich immer, ich mache mir gern mein eigenes Bild und nichts von Vorverurteilung. Deswegen kann ich im Moment nur sagen, dass ich echt zufrieden bin, dass er das gut macht und ein ganz ruhiger Vertreter ist. Er ist auch ein Familienmensch und das schätze ich immer sehr, weil ich auch einer bin. Wie gesagt, ich mag den Umgang, wie er mit der Mannschaft umgeht, und bis jetzt durchweg positiv.
Jetzt bist du 31 Jahre alt und zu dem Verein gewechselt. Hast du jetzt erstmals eine komplett andere Rolle in so einem Team? Du hast mit die meiste Erfahrung, du bist auch einer der Älteren. Was ist deine Rolle bei den Kickers?
Man merkt schon, dass es jetzt nochmal was anderes als Bielefeld ist. In Bielefeld stand ich in der Blüte meiner Zeit, damit 28. Ich sollte schon ein wichtiger Spieler sein, aber jetzt noch nicht so einer wie jetzt. Jetzt hat man mich wirklich geholt, weil man davon überzeugt ist, dass ich da einer der Hauptakteure sein kann, der den eventuellen Wiederaufstieg oder eine gute Rolle in der Saison spielen soll und das bewerkstelligen soll. Das ist jetzt auf jeden Fall etwas anderes. Man merkt schon, dass die Leute hier sehr viel von mir verlangen. Dem will ich auch gerecht werden, was natürlich nicht immer einfach ist, aber es ist schon einfach und ich habe mir das ausgesucht. Deswegen ist es auch wirklich eine riesen Herausforderung, muss ich ehrlich sagen, weil wir jetzt auch nicht so gut gestartet sind und erst so langsam in die Puschen kommen. Ich hoffe, dass ich da noch den Teil dazu beitragen kann, den alle von mir verlangen, aber ich nehme die Herausforderung gerne an und bin auch einer, der sich nicht scheut, die Verantwortung zu übernehmen. Deswegen bin ich mal gespannt, wo uns die Saison noch hinführen wird.
Und was ist Würzburg für einen Fußballstandort verglichen mit Bielefeld, Dresden, Paderborn, Cottbus?
Kann man wenig mit den vorigen Stationen vergleichen. Ich glaube, dass das hier relativ schnell gegangen ist, vielleicht zu schnell, dieser Sprung in den bezahlten Fußball wieder von der Regionalliga in die Zweite Liga innerhalb von zwei Jahren und jetzt wieder zurück. Die Infrastruktur ist noch nicht so, dass man unbedingt sagen kann, dass es alles so sein müsste. Das hängt noch ein bisschen hinterher. Dementsprechend ist die Erwartungshaltung gerade relativ hoch, dass wir es schaffen. Aber da muss man ein bisschen differenzieren. Wir müssen gucken, wir haben jetzt auch 16 neue Spieler und das ist nicht so einfach. Das ist natürlich schön, wenn es von Anfang an klappt, aber es ist keine Garantie dafür, dass wenn du 16 gute Spieler holst, die auch zusammen funktionieren. Das muss man sich erarbeiten. Da muss man im Training sowohl auf dem Platz als auch neben dem Platz viel arbeiten und viel sprechen. Und auch sich zusammenraufen. Das hört sich immer so plakativ an, aber das musst du dir auch erarbeiten, so einen Zusammenhalt in der Mannschaft. Der existiert nicht von allein, sondern das muss man sich über Spiele erarbeiten und über gemeinsame Aktionen, die man macht. Deswegen ist das ein Prozess und der läuft bei uns noch. Der hat bis jetzt noch nicht so geklappt, wie wir es uns vorgestellt haben, aber ich hoffe, dass wir das noch hinkriegen.
Wie ist der Medienstandort Würzburg? Hat man hier mehr Ruhe, um zu trainieren und sich vorzubereiten als in anderen Städten?
Ja, da würde ich schon sagen, viel mehr Ruhe. Es gibt nur eine Zeitung, die berichtet, die Bild ist komplett raus, zumindest in der dritten Liga, es gibt nur die Mainpost und das ist dann schon überschaubar. Ich möchte mal sagen, hier hat man schon seine Ruhe. Nichtsdestotrotz merkt man trotzdem, dass die Leute gern wieder sehen würden, dass man oben mitspielt oder dass man wieder an die Tür klopft zur zweiten Liga. Aber ich bin auch noch dabei, mir das genau anzuschauen. Ich habe mir da noch kein komplettes Bild gemacht. Deswegen ist das noch ein Prozess, der noch nicht abgeschlossen ist.
Und bist du jetzt dann jemand, der auch für die Medienvertreter der erste Ansprechpartner ist?
Früher gab es mal Stimmen in Dresden, die mir das vorgeworfen haben, damit ich mich vor jede Kamera gedrängt hätte. Aber es war einfach aus dem Problem geschuldet, dass wir viele ausländische Spieler hatten, wenige Deutsch konnten und es nur zwei, drei Deutsche waren, die man immer vor die Kamera stellen konnte. In Dresden war natürlich die Nachfrage nach Interviews viel, viel größer als vorhin. Dementsprechend war ich da häufiger zu sehen, was mir selber auch nicht manchmal so recht war. Aber man hat bei uns damals in Dresden gesagt, wenn jemand fragt, dann geht ihr da auch hin und sagt nicht nein, das macht man nicht. Das war damals die Ansage und deswegen war das auch so. Wenn ich hier gefragt werde, dann sage ich meine Meinung dazu und sage die auch offen. Wenn nicht, dann bin ich komplett entspannt damit. Und die wichtige Arbeit ist sowieso die, die man auf dem Platz und im Hintergrund macht und nicht die, die man da vor der Kamera macht. Und deswegen bin ich da wirklich viel, viel erfahrener und viel gelassener geworden. Weil, wie gesagt, du kannst alles erzählen vor dem Mikrofon und alles schönreden. Aber wirklich wichtig ist das, was intern passiert. Und das kriegen natürlich danach ja nicht alle mit. Aber das ist ja auch egal, weil es geht nur um den Erfolg der Mannschaft quasi. Und deswegen ist da eben jedes Mittel recht.
Mir ist aufgefallen, dass du eine bestimmte Körperhaltung hast, immer wenn du Interviews führst, nämlich sehr zurückgenommen. Die Hände hinter dem Körper verschränkt und nicht zurückhaltend, aber kommt eher höflich und offen drüber. Aber du bist auch sehr, sehr ruhig in Interviews. Machst du das bewusst oder ist das unbewusst?
Ich versuche schon ruhig zu bleiben, weil ich nach dem Spiel manchmal sehr schwer eine genaue Analyse zu tätigen. Vor allem in der Hitze des Gefechts, vor allem wenn es ein aufreibendes Spiel war. Ich versuche immer ruhig zu bleiben, um dann so sachlich wie möglich das Spiel zu analysieren. Wenn jemand mich fragt, dann sage ich auch genau, wie es war oder wie ich es empfunden habe. Ich glaube, dass es nicht gut ist, wenn man aus der kompletten Emotion rumschreit und sich dann irgendwelche komischen Aussagen verdaddelt. Deswegen versuche ich immer ruhig zu bleiben. Die Höflichkeit, das heißt von meinem Elternhaus gelernt, das ist für mich ein Grundprinzip meines Daseins, immer höflich zu sein.
Das heißt, es war schon ein reflektierter Prozess, wie du vor den Medien auftritt?
Man musste sich einfach weiterentwickeln, weil wie gesagt, Dresden war so ein Wahnsinnsmarkt dafür, dass da so viele Interviewanfragen und so viel Fernseheradio, Printmedien, da gab es so viele Anfragen, dass man sich einfach auch weiterentwickeln musste, weil du willst ja auch nicht nur Mist plappern, du lernst natürlich auch, dass du besser rüberkommst, wenn du das sagst, was du wirklich denkst und nicht nur das sagst, was die Leute hören wollen. Ja, und was die Leute hören wollen oder was die Leute halt nicht hören wollen, so eine Phrasen halt, so ein blödes Gelaber, wo du eigentlich auch nicht sagen brauchst, bevor du so eine Phrasen sagst. Also da weißt du danach genauso viel wie davor oder der Zuschauer, der das hört. Und deswegen versuche ich, weiß nicht, ob mir das oft gelingt, aber ich versuche einfach, meine Meinung zu sagen und ob dir dann einem gefällt oder nicht, das ist dann eine andere Sache, aber so bin ich zumindest mit mir im Reim.
Abschließende Frage, wenn du dir dein Karriereende malen könntest, wie sähe es aus?
So, dass ich damit komplett zufrieden bin. Das muss nicht in irgendeinem Höhepunkt enden. Aber ich glaube einfach so, dass ich danach sage, hey, jetzt ist es so, dass du merkst, dass du keinem mehr weiterhelfen kannst und dass es wirklich, dass dir von außen jemand oder dass dir dein Körper selbst sagt, es reicht jetzt wirklich. Im Moment bin ich noch gar nicht in diesem Gefühl drin. Wenn ich jetzt morgens aufstehen würde und mir schon alles wehtun würde, dann wäre es vielleicht etwas anderes. Aber so bin ich fit wie nie. Umso älter du bist, umso mehr musst du an deiner Fitness arbeiten und an deiner Ernährung. Ich habe da noch mal einen kompletten Cut gemacht vor Jahren. Ich bin jetzt und toi toi toi weder krank noch verletzt gewesen die letzten Jahre. Deswegen denke ich im Moment darüber noch nicht nach. Ich hoffe, dass ich noch eine Weile spielen kann. Im Endeffekt gibt es nichts Schöneres als das zu machen, was du am besten kannst. Und das als deinen Beruf zu machen. Deswegen möchte ich das schon so lange wie möglich genießen. Aber wie gesagt, mit der Prämisse, dass ich den Leuten weiterhelfen kann, den ich hier diene sozusagen.
Sebastian, das hat großen Spaß gemacht. Vielen Dank. Vielleicht hören wir dich ja auch mal mit einem eigenen Podcast. Ich habe da interessante Pläne erfahren. Wenn es da was gibt, dann wird der Rasenfunk das großmöglich promoten.
Das ist nett.
Sebastian Schuppan, vielen Dank, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast.
Ich danke. Hat mir auch großen Spaß gemacht. Vielen Dank. Und ich werde den Rasenfunk auch weiter supporten, soweit ich das in meiner Macht stehe.
Mega nett. Vielen, vielen Dank. Sebastian Schuppan bei Twitter, add Schuppi27. Da werden wir jetzt noch ein paar Follower draufschaufeln, das verspreche ich dir. Und damit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke fürs Zuhören dieses 13. Tribünengesprächs. Ihr findet unsere anderen Feeds bei iTunes oder wenn ihr einfach auf rasenfunk.de geht. Es gibt noch die Schlusskonferenz, es gibt den Kurzpass und wir reden sehr, sehr viel über Fußball. Und ihr könnt uns unterstützen. Rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen. Und in diesem Sinne, vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit bis zu diesem Punkt. Und dann bis zur nächsten Sendung hier im Rasenfunk. Das war das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.